dude
you're watching age to the three three
three three
you're watching the three three three
three
yeah i was just joking that jay-z is
gonna sue us now
join the party baby
if he did first of all welcome everybody
welcome welcome to h3 after dark
i was we're very late i was dealing with
lawyers and all kinds of crap this
morning so i'm a little pissy
[Applause]
family family family family family stop
family family then binge
family family family family family
family family and
family
wow that's good
it's emotional
powerful stuff
today's episode is sponsored by meundies
hello fresh hbo max and liquid iv we
love them all so well
ryan kavanaugh has been going eight i'm
not gonna talk about ryan up so but he's
been going hey
ape crap
check this out hold on hold on
i'm getting some inert so i'm getting
some interference from somebody
what does that mean
um
what does interference mean oh we have
an audio issue no yeah uh there's
somebody uh oh barboy
yo
gabe looking good
nice shades
thanks you got some new shades is this
your new look
it's my new look right now because i'm
number one on cameo yeah i saw that
gabe are you number one because i saw an
i don't i saw an article he's in the top
yeah he's in the top five most booked
cameo creators of 2021 what on earth
wow
how does that feel
it feels good baby
i'm hollywood now baby
you are hollywood
just don't change yeah never change
don't let the success go to your head
okay oh yeah of course because no one
can [ __ ] with me baby [ __ ] they [ __ ]
you're untouchable now
would you say you're untouchable now
it looks like it baby [ __ ] they [ __ ]
yeah yeah you're a made man now [ __ ]
baby
[ __ ] are you are you making some
hollywood elite friends no
um i don't want to go into that i'd
rather have my real friends
hollywood
hollywood elite friends are like they
don't care for me if i'm if i'm going to
get sick or i'm going to suffer yeah my
real friends do care about me that's all
right that's all about family have you
yeah have you gotten an invitation to
epstein's island yet or no
nope no
okay good i just checked in because you
got you're getting pretty famous
well it's friday i don't think there's
school or work to tomorrow is there
of course not
it's the weekend it's the weekend
yeah baby see let's see um
who who your contemporaries are who's
brian baumgarten who's this loser
brown gown i haven't heard of him he's
from the office
you're in the you're in the greats as
kevin from the office wow
oh okay
that's epic and then sonya morgan anyone
know who that is
reality tv no clue reality star the real
i never heard of these modern stuff
oh real housewives of new york it's her
oh i don't even recognize her i don't
watch that i don't watch that show so
yeah nobody does nobody cares about her
she's gonna
lose her ass
okay
who is he he was a youtuber
uh he's been in broadway shows okay
wow that's good company um
white claw gabe and then of course
uh legendary tick tock creator white
clock gabe wow
oh my god
congratulations buddy congrats thanks
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] with me
there aren't too many legends around
well
what are you doing this weekend anything
fun
right i probably gotta watch a play
see my family perform on a
dance show something tomorrow and then
there's the fight
there's the fight tomorrow too
[ __ ] baby
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
all right gabe well listen i'm so happy
for you it's a well-deserved title
and uh i think you know it sky's the
limit for white claw gabe this is only
the
beginning oh yeah
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby
happy weekend baby happy weekend gabe
congratulations on your big reward uh or
uh
oh you're developing some new uh some
new moves i think he was goofing on me a
little bit oh okay yeah
i just made that up just now
that's why he's the best people that's
why he's the best
all right gabe you have a great weekend
okay i know you will all right crush
some white clothes
all right
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] it's friday baby
yeah so i was that's huge man what god
gave just that cameo it's just powerful
powerful stuff he's gone to hollywood
yeah dude kevin from the office made
over a million dollars last year
what does he charge i wonder how many
cameras he's 65 is when he made his
million that's what he was charging so
you gotta be cranking those yeah that's
a lot of cameos a million divided by 165
that's well after six thousand cameos
bruh after cameo's cut that's a lot more
too
well hold on hold on three is 65 oh
sorry yeah we're in the matrix 6 000
divided by 365 is on average he's doing
16 per day i guess that's doable
i mean it's definitely doable
wait what is that that makes it sound
like we're at the doctor or something
like a machine
the digitizing
it's when we're doing calculations no
not that you hear the i think you're
hearing the wash yeah the dishwasher oh
the dishwasher oh yeah not a sound bite
loudest dishwasher
yeah so anyway
ryan kavanaugh is offering a 25 000
bounty
here read this
the amount of dms i'm getting with
information on what he has done to
others is baffling
[Laughter]
you mean the amount of people trolling
me
this is baffling this is what's funny he
goes i'm considering throwing an
instagram 25 000 giveaway for most
disturbing stories someone can prove he
has done so far the ones i got pretty
disturbing so on one hand ryan's like i
can't believe all the dm's i'm getting
from h3 fans and on the other hand he's
soliciting messages
yeah isn't that a little [ __ ] ironic
yeah a little bit just a little bit
ironic 25 000 for dirt though that's
what i'm thinking of applying i got
who's got better dirt than me yeah well
go ahead get that get that money
i was trying to think he doesn't
understand how the internet works at all
no he has no idea
it's crazy it's obvious it's awesome
that this is the i mean
you've got to appreciate how amazing
this is ryan cavanaugh who fancies
himself this uh serious businessman who
called our podcast a toy podcast
has debased himself to [ __ ] posting
about me on a now daily basis if you go
to his instagram
what is this this appears to be love's
twitter account
with a receipt for two
dollars from paypal
oh
[Music]
yeah there we go
you're so quick on that
nursery music thank you
let me make sure to hide this oh yeah
um
yeah i was thinking like let's see when
i was uh
let's see when i was
13 i got caught with a playboy is that
good enough oh i could i don't know if i
can prove it you can't buy those as a
miner you can't do that no that was
illegal yeah be in possession of uh i
can't believe you're admitting this on
the air right now well i want that 25
000.
you know do you think it'll just be you
know the the series finale of seinfeld
when they're on trial and it's like
everybody they've like slightly wronged
over the years yeah that's going to be
this trial it's going to just be like
we can call it to the witness stand
soflo antonio antonio ricegum uh matt
haas
prank invasion
yeah [ __ ] wait not this this is not
what i meant to say ryan cavanaugh yeah
so this is a guy who runs a huge media
company who clearly doesn't understand
social media at all
uh it's [ __ ] ironic and also just a
shout out to does ryan cavanaugh look
like harvey weinstein.com
definitely click that
but what i wanted to open was this
instagram page
um so you guys can see
how prolific of a [ __ ] poster
he's become
here's one
you're gonna have to i'm not gonna read
all these but he's tagging all of our
sponsors who incidentally also don't
i don't wanna necessarily be the one to
tell him this but
uh domino's doesn't sponsor us [ __ ]
because he got a
silly
he got a domino's pre-roll
and he started tagging dominoes on
[ __ ] instagram
i know how that's a boomer ass he has no
pizza experience there's no pizza
experience i don't know what he's really
he's trying to call cause the nessa
adpocalypse because this is what happens
right this is keemstar's bff right
you know once you start just tagging
ad advertisers who don't sponsor me but
who just are being served through
youtube's
system that's how you call because of
the apocalypse right there boy yep just
a toy entrepreneur
it's true because he's playing with his
daddy's money so
it's not even real entrepreneurship
yeah so he tagged let's see uh dominoes
okay
let's get domino's let's get dominoes to
pull the ads from youtube apparently
ryan
so there's one post here about uh
some random account leaving of nasty
comment which apparently he's saying
that let me talk to the manager of
domino's yeah karen kavanagh
[Laughter]
i don't want to have anal sex
i didn't okay
it's fun because his hair is also red so
it really
meshes you know yeah
yeah so there's this one there's this
one he's tagging all of our sponsors
apparently this is a dm of some
random dude who
sent him a nasty uh message
and he went
[ __ ] tagging all of our sponsors and
going ape [ __ ] adam and eve it's like
when you talk oh and then he tag wait
and then attorney tom's the guy who said
the lawsuit i i uh he is out of his mind
that's the guy that was commenting
yeah he's like yo you should check out
this ryan cavanaugh stuff
it's really dangerous for the creator
community if he wins these lawsuits
and i just tweeted him out a couple days
ago and gave him a shout out
and now he's tagging him on instagram he
says
uh uh let's see he promotes the law firm
attorney tom who is now acting like a
disinterested party what are you talking
about uh what
this more the string is pulled the more
interesting the story will get
what is he thinking
[Laughter]
the guy posted on facebook and i
reposted him what's so [ __ ]
mysterious bro
yeah so that's two posts
um
here's ryan kavanagh who photoshopped
himself into his own birthday party
hang on wait
yeah look he's photoshopped himself in
he's not there
we had a discussion about this this
morning this is a stock photo that can't
be true i talked to an expert he had to
look at it a few times but he did not
believe that it is photoshopped i'm
kidding i don't think it's photoshopping
oh man it totally looks like it stops
that would have been the funniest
[ __ ] thing in the world well he
doesn't have actual friends i mean who
are these people and these are paid
employees
actors
why are they all wearing black it seems
like they work there or something that's
all the wait staff that's why they're
all wearing black these are all the
weight staff okay gotcha oh okay the
fact that you said they're all wearing
black made me think that maybe it is a
photoshop
i didn't even know it looks like a stock
photo it does and then ryan photoshopped
himself in there
like bro
i'm sorry but do these people know that
you think black lives matter is a uh
george soros george a jewish conspiracy
that's awesome or did he say that on
twitter yeah he tweeted it he said that
black lives matter is just uh funded by
george soros and it's like some [ __ ]
movement pretty good right pretty pretty
hot take nice guy
yeah
sweetheart and then um
it's just like basically his whole feed
is just
dedicated to me i mean there's another
here's another so it's pretty epic you
know
you could say oculus who does he think
that cares about it except you know like
our own fans
yeah our own fans are though exactly
who is he posting all this stuff for
that's a great question ela that's a
great question he thinks he's an
influencer because he bought
a hundred thousand likes
let's see
here's the tweet it's still up that's
what's so interesting
he says 90 of black
black deaths by black people
blm funded by george soros trying to
create conflict oh my god that's like
just straight up some races [ __ ] right
there boy love that just watching my
algorithms get crushed
so you know
you could say i occupy a lot of space in
his mind
so yeah if you guys have any good
pitches i mean
i would i mean that's a lot of money so
25 000 you know
we shouldn't
we shouldn't tell people to
to dm him at all though i'm not
well pitching him the thing will he okay
first of all do not i i don't know how
many times i have to say this because he
keeps lying and saying i'm encouraging
people to send him death threats don't
message him don't interact with him
don't send him death threats you're not
a super trooper you're not part of the
family if you're doing any of those
things that being said he is offering 25
000 so if you have dirt on me right i
would i wouldn't i would i would urge
you to get that for proof in that paper
right okay looking for proven
dirt
every day talk to keemstar so i don't
know what more he's looking for he
already got the keemstar dustin i mean
he probably has the kinster folder
already on his desktop yeah that should
have everything
he's got the dossier that's what i'm
saying but yeah if you if you gotta get
it after it
watched it before long he's going to
start talking about how i embezzled the
fupa money
that would
that would be amazing yeah that would be
the that larry on top of everything that
would be peak [ __ ]
that would be peak [ __ ]
yeah i mean dantdm at all um i do have
to i mean
we have no idea i i not to get too
conspiratorial but the people that hate
you um
you know sending him nasty stuff like
that in order to make you look bad uh
does seem like an angle that some people
might think of but
who knows i don't know what do you mean
like the people that are sending them
death threats and stuff i mean
well i want to believe that our fans
aren't that stupid i mean don't do that
oh you're saying it could be and i don't
know i mean look there's a lot of dumb
people it's not i have nothing to do
with what other people do i'm saying
don't do that right so like i'm i can't
be held liable for what other people do
i mean i'm saying don't do it don't
message him yeah i don't think they're
sending them him those messages but i do
know that i get those messages all the
[ __ ] time bro you know also at this
point this story
is picking up so other people are
hearing about it too yes exactly this is
the internet right people will message
him yeah just never i mean ever ever do
it
never be a baby no
no whatever never ever do it it is death
[Laughter]
you know and um
you know and
yeah
i don't i stay out of my unsolicited
messages because it's all death threats
and [ __ ] anti-semitism and [ __ ]
so that's it okay jews that's all i have
to say about that
but i am i've got pretty good uh
groundwork for the h3 video i think it's
going to be an absolute banger
excited it's gonna be a banger i'm
excited for that
did i thank our sponsors already
you did
me undies hellofresh hbo max and liquid
iv who we love so well yeah we say it
again we love them why not family family
family
family family family family family
family family family family what is this
like man first edit that you've met
so um it's him in the hell wind tunnel
if you go against the family go straight
to hell yeah
so
basically
well basically guys oh love's
coming love god i'm coming he's coming
to america
i'm gonna come
i'm gonna come so you're coming next
month right
um yes that's right yep
[Music]
just for the sun like can you say you're
going to come
i'm going to come
oh you got it there we go you messed up
love now he has them
i don't mind no yeah i'm very excited
very very excited have you been to
america before
uh yeah when i was like 13 i was in
new york
okay
yep
but since i know
by the way
like we found this ela's mom's in town
i forget why
i'm not allowed to talk about it
she just happens to be here
coincidentally yeah
no such thing but um
she brought this wedding
she brought this wedding
book
from me and hila's wedding i've never
seen those people i'm saying now those
are stock images yeah those are good for
those people
by my crooked ass hunchback looking ass
look at that beta stance look at that
angle
thanks photographer could have told me
that i'm stand up straight or something
yeah
oh you do okay
you pass me a tissue from there
you start crying
no oh oh you're gonna go from there it
looks emotional yeah you guys want to
see this i mean i haven't looked at
these in a long time man it's it's like
a whole different world
yeah so this thing is so heavy that i
never
thought i would bring it with me
anywhere and then finally my mom brought
it over
this was
in
october
of 2012
yeah
10 10 2012 which would be now
uh nine or yeah nine years ago
right
over nine years ago
okay you can see it
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
so waiting for
nah daniel enough of daniel
is that the first public photo of you
guys kissing
maybe i i feel like you guys used to
meet me a lot in your old videos
your dress is so pretty ela thank you
you're sick
well i'm waiting for okay let's see what
we got here
[Music]
can we just use your your mobile uh
maybe whatever
steady hands of course i'm coming right
over always well give it to dan
so people don't say that we
what's the deal do you have a tremor
people go like oh you might not make fun
of
what's and then
you have a tremor
come here come here
let's see your hands
let's see if we i thought you were just
nervous
no
i just can't keep them still oh
interesting
have you had that diagnosed yeah
what did they say it's just like an
essential tremor or something
it's a mild tremor yeah but like
whenever i have caffeine or anything
it's a lot worse
and usually when i'm doing the show i
just came in or whatever it is
i said coffee it's like i'm extra i'm
sorry for not being sensitive to that oh
no it's okay
but with that app
and i and i've said this a million times
when i say it again it removes the in
body stabilization ben's nodding his
head because he's sick of me explaining
it but you know what's interesting and i
i think we've talked about it but ian
also has a tremor yeah
can we have you guys come shake hands
and see what that looks like ian makes
me look straight solid
yeah i'm a little and then what what is
it called what you have it's just a
tremor as well and just a essential
tremor yeah a central trimmer essential
oh it's a only the essentials yeah
it's essential exactly love me daddy
what's a non-essential yeah what's a
non-essential uh tremor
i don't even wanna know right
that's low-level [ __ ]
my boxing coach was wrapping my hands
for the first time he's like what's
wrong with you
he's straight to the point yeah i'm like
no i'm like i am nervous but that's not
why i'm shaking
that's the annoying part is when
everyone assumes you're just like
terrified you're nervous all the time
i'm like i'm fine yeah
i'm sorry if i i i honestly just thought
you were nervous on camera
but yeah but it's like what are the
chances that we got two guys with
tremors yeah
what are the one guy with the right
shaky king and one guy
yeah
anyone else want to come forward
i have this blinking thing sometimes oh
really let me see well it's like when
i'm not
it's like when i'm really focusing on
[ __ ] i'll just like start like blinking
pretty pretty yeah pretty hastily i'm
having nothing i thought we had it back
yeah how you live with that i just take
three sips of beer
i take three sips in the morning
are you ready dan yeah the pressure's on
now i'm gonna take three sips at night
all right
a little shaky i'm telling you it is
a little shaky i've used
maybe bring it um
bring it in there there is
sean look at this
that's my brother
sean that's sean
these are friends these are people we
worked with
here we are kissing just
basking it
do that
stop
um these are great photos i had to prove
to everyone that i could lift her
i can lift you right i'm pretty strong
ela i've lived here with me i'm strong
right yeah thank you very strong you're
also tall
i'm tall and strong and your hands and
you're smart
thank you for noticing
absolutely this is just like friends
lots of friends and co-workers and stuff
hey that's gary
my dad oh yeah there's right yeah yeah
more
more you know stuff um
friends fam mom
family we got so drunk that was such a
fun night though
do you guys deputy in israel i don't
know if it's called something different
do what like the line dancing like we
should on the dance floor do we what
depkay it's like where you put your
hands around the
like everyone and like put one leg up
no we didn't no
i guess the the comparable would be the
horror right
what do you call it the horse i guess
maybe some people we did the chairs
stick
maybe it depends where your family is
from
yeah we did the chair thing it was a
great night though with lots of drinks
yeah great food
good old just a good old time right
there
so it was good music
oh yeah we picked the playlist
you know ela's friends from art school
he was friends from
childhood childhood
my parents
some of my co-workers that's what people
really want to see right there
the donark
don arc's arrives don arks rise up
here's lots of donarky
here's um
my sister with
with uh one of the someone from ela's
family
oh my god my brother what was this my
brother was getting frisky with someone
who is that oh she's from my art school
my god
i didn't know that's what's going on did
you
nope damn my brother was
sean
sean
and then
shout out shout out to yochanon having a
good time as well with cigarette in one
hand and
cigar
oh yeah
i don't know cigarette and cigar
sounds like stage four cancer
jesus
but yeah basically right
wow this is flattering to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyways a good old time lots of uh
schmoozin and schmutzen
dearly uh
lots of love
you i'll show you the weird part though
okay
that's when we got married i stomped the
glass
you see how people dressed there it's
like
so freaking casual dude
um
yeah you're right my brother was wearing
jeans your dad was wearing nice pants
too we had an argument about that
oh i was saying he wore jeans yeah but
you're right my brother was yeah people
always wear jeans to israeli weddings
like that's it that's fancy i love that
um you should see what shawn balog was
wearing
[Music]
okay wait here i want to show you the
part that i didn't expect okay here oh
here we go
yeah the [ __ ] rabbi took my ass to
the side
and i had to write up a contract about
how
what
i'm worth or something yeah how much ela
was worth
if we got divorced for something how
much i would owe your family or
something like that
we had to put a number right yeah i had
to put a number and ila wasn't allowed
obviously this was for the men and my
dad's there like he [ __ ] has anything
to say about it
you know you negotiated i was like hold
on my lawyer is not here
and they're like just put something with
18 it's a good luck number
so
right yeah happy here man what
is wrong with you dude what are you
doing weirdo
you look good
yeah i look good but not happy
[Laughter]
that was a great day it was a happy day
very happy day
by the way that contract doesn't mean
anything i have no idea what it means me
and lena had to do a contract like that
we always question if it was legal or
not i don't think it's illegal at all
a rabbi was there they take that [ __ ]
seriously in israel
i don't even have according to that
contract if we get divorced i only need
to give you like 10 bucks
don't [ __ ] around
[ __ ]
again what the [ __ ] is this
oh they were trying to get us to make
some photos before
this he found some random girls we were
like out of kibbutz
by the way look at this one this one
cracked me up why are we what the [ __ ]
is that photo
i was like dude what the [ __ ] he's like
yo get on that bike it'll be awesome and
then look how you're hunched over like
you just look cold and confused
so dumb
so dumb so dumb
love it though
there you go see happy smile
here i'm on the phone i mean yeah doing
business on my nokia
mama nokia
hold on baby the wedding can wait
i've got serious business
oh geez
beautiful bride
gorge
gorge gorge
gorge stand up gorgeous bride
[Music]
beautiful beautiful
that's a nice photo got a smile looking
handsome
thank you
how's the hairline is it the same it's
the same yeah
it's growing stronger stronger you think
yeah king [ __ ]
okay that's good
i don't know are you sure there's not a
little receding here like in the corner
just a tiny bit no
no
no get a close-up there so that people
can really see you beautiful hair
yeah and show the back the the
the brother banks there's a little
there's a little
oh i got he was wearing a hat it's the
hat
okay all right
just making sure
again the chopper like oh are you
kidding me yes
i don't know whose bike that was
he just told me they're in the mirror oh
yeah and then he took a photo of us in
the mirror it's like okay dude damn
nobody asked for that and then here's
some random girl who's like i don't know
why i'm here
the sons of donarki
thank you
oh you
that's what happened you were doing it
backwards
i was like this is not the chronological
order oh oh cause it's in the oh
okay okay and anyway i was like i had
never seen this but yeah beautiful okay
wow gorgeous what a finale wow look at
me look at my heart look the [ __ ] bro
it's like a turtle come on have you
stand up straight or get closer or
something it's like
horrible
but okay good memories all right
love you love you happy birthday
thank you we have a fun weekend planned
i'm excited i'm excited too yeah it's
gonna be great
now the the dishwasher dishwasher
like a canary
yeah for my elina's wedding they asked
me on the spot and i have never heard of
this prior where i have to
give a value on lena oh yeah we didn't
know about
it was so awkward i made a joke like oh
i'll give her the tv and like linda's
parents my parents are standing there
this chef is standing there
was it a nice tv it's nice you know 60
inch samsung yeah that's good
oh we were dead broke then so like
they're asking me to put a value and i'm
like
yeah i have not thought about this
i think i ended up writing something
bro i don't even know this shit's
embarrassing
it's so embarrassing so what'd you end
up riding
the like lowest because we're broke too
the lowest you could assign is like a
trip to mecca like which is like one of
the five pillars of islam you have to go
visit mecca that's it you get you you
get a divorce and then you get you just
send them off to mecca she gets a
religious trip that's what she gets if
we get a divorce
kill off the mecca yo yo you'll figure
your [ __ ] out
it works though because then you just
tell the family you know i'm a religious
guy that's what we got to do are you go
with her she goes solo she was solo
so you dropped her ass
for some new young hot girl
and then she goes off to mecca never be
heard from again
that's that's awesome eli i'm gonna send
your ass to the wall if we get the word
i'm just gonna send you to the uh
wailing wall and just wish you well
one of my favorite images of you ethan
is you on that
wall with their hands up yeah that was
that took balls of steel it was pretty
scary
i i didn't think anyone would hurt me or
anything but i was afraid we would get
kicked out this one here
i mean that the thing is my my goal with
this was just for people to think that i
was um
just really praying
because these because these guys get so
[ __ ] passionate about the western
wall so they're doing [ __ ] that
looks pretty wild so i was like well i
should blend in
hey we skipped the page but there was
one guest that's worth a mention that
was out
oh cap cap was there [ __ ] i don't care
about that
wait he's photoshopped in this time for
sure
no
no this looks real who invited that
[ __ ] tomorrow
stalker he's awesome
love that
[ __ ] ryan cavanaugh let's watch this
[ __ ]
yeah we went to western wall to shoot a
sketch
it turned out awesome
and there's a
you're not allowed to film down there
right ela so the holy spirit had to get
along really long shot of me
and uh it's no it's also that women can
go with men yeah it's separated so the
women get a tiny little piece of that
[ __ ]
and the men get all that
all that sweet all that space to stretch
your balls out
here's the wall you cause you're oh yeah
here's the other watch
this is this was fun to hang on it's
like the neighbor from home improvement
guys swinging our [ __ ] get all this
hey don't say anything to me this is the
men's side hey hey get back in there
it's so funny yeah
people come here to pray
and uh
a lot of fun
i love how you act all startled
i don't think so
i took a few though i'm kidding
yeah i took a few
you know
keep it real keep it
55th
oh
man what do we got today let's see we
are at 38 minutes so we should do a
couple of our sponsors
here here you ready for this just to set
you guys up new ace family house tour oh
let's go
and pewdiepie said that
pewdiepie attacked viciously came after
our uh harvey
ryan cavanaugh right
and uh nickacado
is about to come on i think we're
closing the deal to get our nicky boy
nikki baby
closing the deal
yeah we're in escrow
yeah we're an escrow
the negotiations are stiff
they are uh
it's contentious but we are steadily
making our way through negotiations with
nicocado
all right let's thank our sponsors first
of all me undies
glorious
beautiful breathable underwear
it's almost the end of 2021 which means
for the next few weeks we're roasting
chestnuts and those aren't the only nuts
that are going to roast
if you're not wearing me undies
are they right
breathable thank you zach you need those
breathable ones so your nuts don't roast
uh listen are you more of a onesie
person or a matching pajama set person
ela
matching pajamas yeah well you can get
both options at me undies you know their
sleepwear like their underwear is
extremely comfortable and i sleep great
in them it's breathable it's comfy it's
cozy and we match
so you just know you match and that
makes that matters it does
it's like a set bonus you know when you
play a video game you get a set bonus
yeah
put it in terms you guys can understand
uh get your festivities on with my
undies holiday collection featuring
classic plaids you know and love and
sweater inspired prints that will
quickly become favorites they're me
undies loungewear and sleepwear made out
of soft breathable stretchy fabrics that
are ideal for sitting fireside with
loved ones and chatting about life over
a cup of hot cocoa get the family photo
you've dreamed of with matching pj sets
or make every day a spa day with the new
plush robes and plush slippers whatever
you decide everyone will be rolling into
the new year comfier than before
available in sizes extra small through
four xl mandy's has a little something
for everyone on your list so
mandy's has a great offer for our
listeners any first time purchase you
get 15 off and free shipping right to
your door your days of fighting for your
life in the mall parking lot are over to
get 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction
guaranteed
go to
slash h3 that's me undies dot com slash
h3
and
uh finally hello fresh
you guys know what it is with hellofresh
it's america's favorite
pre-portioned ingredients seasonal
recipes service
delivered right to your door this is of
course a b made this beautiful burrito
uh it is mature yeah you can go ahead
and click that dan
yeah it's mature that burrito is not
safe for work
it gets me rock hard every time i see
that burrito
[Music]
why is uh hello fresh america's number
one meal kit um well i'll tell you all
about it
they're gonna send you a package
refrigerated with ice pre-portioned
fresh ingredients
detailed instructions how to make a
perfect home-cooked meal that's
delicious fresh nutritious you're gonna
if you're not comfortable cooking you're
gonna learn how to cook
if you do know how to cook you might
still pick up some things but one
thing's for sure is that it's gonna be
delicious what have we got here some
salmon or something
i think it's actually mahi mahi
i mean that's what i'm saying this is
delicious nutritious wholesome meal i
mean look how good that looks you know
and you know the holidays can be hectic
but hello fresh it helps keep things
simple with the recipe that cut backs on
meal prep cleanup so you can spend less
time in the kitchen more quality time
with friends and family
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door within a week so you can get the
convenience without skimping on quality
plus skip trips to the grocery store and
avoid long holiday lines
you know the super troopers been loving
it and people have been sending us
photos in our discord which we love to
see
so keep it up for troopers and enjoy and
if you go to hellofresh.com
after dark 14 and use code after dark 14
you can get up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts
that's hellofresh.com afterdark14 and
use the code after dark 14 for up to 14
free meals
america's number one meal kit
thank you hello fresh
all right
so um
let's talk about let's i guess let's
watch pewdiepie slam kavanaugh
why not vicious
this is such a savage clip it's
savage
i mean the only person more savage in
pewdiepie and who's more savage than
pewdiepie oh you know
uh why are you asking me because i know
you know this is your meme
uh come on this is you this is your name
davidson yes pete davidson
ian's always going on about pete
davidson's savage takedowns i'm a
[ __ ] savage you got to do it i'm
always getting them recommended on
youtube pete david is he really savage
moment compilation yeah is he sad i
didn't know he was a savage
that's what i'm youtube thank you pete
davidson
savage moments those are always on my
home page pete davidson's most funny
savage moments
i didn't realize he was such a savage
yeah can you guys start making um
savage compilations of me i feel like
i'm more stable than pizza
a little bit
i want to be savage
it might look like my body has been
savaged
it's been
yeah i can't say seven 21 savage is
basically like my spirit animal and [ __ ]
jesus christ oh my god dude i heard
steve will do it his girlfriend's
pregnant bro
god bless congratulations steve i'm sure
you'll be okay he doesn't live in texas
does he role model of a father oh
god
[Laughter]
no no no
he's making today
i have to say um i was listening to the
whole bit about the dolphins and that
was super funny oh thank you somebody
that understands my humor i guess
there's a reason we did get married
do you guys remember the conversation
about the dolphins consent more than
like dogs we're sorry about that thought
it was funny
who said it wasn't funny it was funny
i guess it was funny thank you
it was funny it was funny it's not funny
it's one of the only funny things you
ever said oh thank you oh wait sorry
that was a savage moment add that to the
compilation whoa dad
all right let's watch uh pewdiepie
demolish ryan harvey from
harvey weinstein god damn it
get your word straight jack
and i play the game more alone but chad
is saying whatever you were talking
about is uh a prank or clickbait or
something wait what what did i get
clickbaited on the pregnant girlfriend
oh she's not actually pregs
maybe
i'm just saying that in the chat so i'm
just a bunch of nut boys in the chat
it's a prank
okay i guess he's not which is good
because i one hand was gonna be like you
know
children are beautiful gifts to this
planet but on the other hand steve will
do it is gonna be giving his
two-year-old son a shotgun and beer with
him
and that's probably not good
all right let's watch pewdiepie
absolutely ravage harvey's uh kavanaugh
ryan cavanaugh
and it's at uh three minutes or
something let's see
what happens uh
ryan kavanagh who do you know what's
happened as well it's a cool fountain
holder
it's so funny that he's watching him
while he's live streaming
[ __ ] shout out to his family dude
[Laughter]
it's a little savage yeah it's
moderately what's what's like savage
light
savage light would be um
he threw shade that would be like a step
below
savaging someone
a nick he's nicking him yeah connect
them uh
maybe
maybe a splinter
what did you hear about i didn't hear
about it i didn't hear anything he said
it must just be a swedish thing that's
how love is he's that fast too whenever
he's making these little edits i was
actually about to say i usually watch
the podcast on to expand when i'm
working what
yeah i know i'll listen i'll listen on
two times if i'm doing research for
something that i don't want to be
listening to but i have to for work
sometimes but i've been watching
something i enjoy damn
and so i think that's why it's like it's
especially bad with the uh
yeah he talks fast yeah
maybe y'all are just on your brains have
uh when i when i edit the podcast i
actually usually and going through it at
2x speed as well i'm not really
different though because you're working
yeah exactly sure yeah but it's on live
stream yeah i mean people are why okay
all right
wait you gotta not pitch ship you gotta
that's just how that program works when
you speed it up you can ok
individually
and then that loss relationship right
right right other claims
including the fight should fall under
fair use which then leads us to
yesterday ryan kavanagh wrote an essay
out of the dark side of the power of
social media explaining more about his
recent lawsuit and why he's saying that
he filed it there he's all right it's
quite a bit after this he's putting a
lot of money in this hundreds
wait wait it's it's further down it's
around 356. but i'm enjoying the philly
d well
by all means then yeah i'm learning a
lot
willing to settle then quote against all
common legal practices rather than
negotiating a good faith he disclosed
his views on the suicide settlement on
his podcast and millions of years ago
yeah that's kind of bad isn't it that's
what the [ __ ] i'm saying bro is that
first of all you're referencing his
article which is full of [ __ ] no no no
he immediately after this he's like if
that's true i don't know because he i
heard that he didn't watch the whole
video
so he just got
ranked kevin on the side no he got he
got yourself you got yourself yeah you
got both okay good
calm down
you should watch the whole video
probably shouldn't do that
i don't know if that's true or not
there's a bad faith tactic
despite the fact that i'm a shareholder
and co-founder i am not trailer among
other things accusing even trying to use
video titles i mean
okay we're getting into the nitty-gritty
here
this is why i sent this detailed
statement to philly though because i was
like i don't want people just to read
ryan's dumb ass [ __ ] article
and then think that that's what it is
when someone searches the name ryan
cavanaugh ryan adding that even
followers have amplified the attacks
right now specifically alleging that a
despite the fact that he's never met
even even opposing more than eight
podcasts
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm not angry at pewdiepie i was just
like that's how that's how ryan wanted
this to go right exactly yeah make sure
he watched google search results
he's encouraged three fans to attack him
online and threaten his family and
additionally brought up a variety
article that even referenced in the past
with a headline that says ryan was
assumed to write a ponzi scheme orion
arguing that even is bringing up this
article and bad faith because an update
in the story knows the situation with
solving the complaint was never
intentionally filed right and also he
was even making other demonstratory
remarks that claims that ryan is not
properly paid his employees or nanny and
that he's gotten two d wise which ryan
says it's false kevin also alleging that
he's not editors who quote destroy his
page with negative positions started
thread for people to plan tax against
him and load about their successes and
caused his followers and paid bonds to
give the trailer wrap up a bad online
race ryan saying all of this amounts of
textbook malicious behavior intended
harmony and trilogy this leaves me with
no choice but to see actually
i say it's not false i'm just referring
to the headline
ethan doesn't watch on 2x he watches on
pause
[Laughter]
well here i have an idea let's slow it
down
or like half speed i think would yeah
so that's it one malignant internet
personality
just sounds too slow hold on
we're gonna go for 75 speed
let's see
isn't this after the lawsuit though that
he started doing all this [ __ ]
yes
okay get back to philly okay we heard
one side of the
argument
the king child with a load of guns
disproportionately harm to anyone using
lies slander and seo and suffer from
no i don't want to actually watch it
like that
we've already watched philly's uh
report on it
or if we want to get really crazy
we could now double this speed oh let's
go and see what happens
all right let's actually make this
watchable this is
stupid
all right playing the accusations from
one side what does the other side so
with that reached out to ethan klein for
a comment or a response regarding the
accusations or any of this in general
and he gave a lengthy response even
starting off by saying ryan cavanaugh's
first malicious lie is that he claims i
pirated his event series is at the heart
of this lawsuit same as with our first
lawsuit use the short clip of the event
during an extremely critical commentary
during a three-hour podcast brian
cavanagh blamed me for his event being
widely pirated which is pure defamation
he didn't even react to the event until
days after it was streamed on
pay-per-view if he cared about pirates
why did he drop all of his other
lawsuits against actual pirates but only
kept the one against me i've heard about
that i think
sick
this thing's targeted if that's the case
accused
harassment asking why his wife's teddy
fresh brand is listed in the suit when
he says it has nothing to do with the
case
right online claiming he's actually done
the opposite of multiple occasions
serious particles that address some of
the specific accusations ryan made
including the writing situation we
mentioned even claiming they made it
clear that the accusation was retracted
and that if ryan quote has a problem
with the article hold on why am i
watching this in glorious 144p
are you because i was wondering oh this
is the max quality okay i was wondering
it's 360 max
badass [ __ ] yeah variety one of the most
trusted new sources of entertainment not
me even addressing ryan's claims and
spreading false information right that's
good
that's a fair point
thank you felix there's a problem with
uh
media doing a bad job at updating i
don't know if it's not is that his
responsibility
hell
no even though he's just referencing
information made available in articles
by well-regarded news sources morning
the three new york times articles from
2008 to say that ryan was charged for
drunk driving in 2006 and was arrested
for the same thing again in 2008 also
sharing a vanity fair article that
brings up the same arrests regarding
about ryan not paying his annie even
pointed to an article from fox san diego
that says orion's foreign
after she was abruptly fired in 2020.
just two months into a contract that was
meant to last over a year and even
writing again i am not reading any of
these claims we're merely reading what
has already been published
i i can i can't understand philly okay
it is fast though you know i don't
i mean you're not a native speaker maybe
that's yeah and bonds to get driller
negative reviews even said that ryan is
slowly blaming him when other big
influencers have been critical it's
going to be hard to prove that in corn i
think as well including noah back the
trailer advisor and made a tick tock i
mean for ryan
even claiming he's only told his fans to
give honest and genuine reviews even
though i was going on to share a
hollywood report article where investor
reportedly told a judge a town full of
scam artists posers false prophets and
flim-flam men ryan c cavanaugh is in a
hollywood class by himself even also
linked to articles from variety and
deadline to say a judge found ryan
fabricated a memo which included phone
sexual harassment claims against an
executive at his previous production
company even closing his statement us by
saying capitalism well i don't
understand why nobody's faced by that
that to me is like the one of the
craziest things i've ever heard
the false the fake memo thing and i feel
like it just washes over people like
they don't register how [ __ ] up it is
because it's so [ __ ] up
you know it's so [ __ ] up it's hard to
register
yeah
it's like no he
he he he it it
a business elite who is used to suing
harassing and breaking the law with no
consequences he wields the legal system
like a malignant tyrant uses it to
silence his critics and now to stifle
fair use something we all on youtube
should care about even also just the
entire situation with ryan on twitter
writing brian kevin is trying to get my
channel banned from youtube a powerful
media person has gone to every lane to
destroy me for criticizing everyone
needs to pay attention now not only is
online but powerful trying to shut down
channels for criticism and then going to
wikipedia user who he thinks might be
ryan saying that the user admitted to
sending legal notices to you and twitch
to get h3
all right
quite a pickle
it keeps coming
up people
shows ryan laying out some of the
accusations we just mentioned and
wanting even to stop so you have all of
that but then there's also an aspect of
the
story
there's a lot of activations being
thrown around a lot of drama it was done
really well by eric gardner
well
he says that uh he looks like harvey
weinstein so i do think that there is
some value i think most of all
if you google ryan kavanagh
i swear to god he really does like it's
kind of a
universal thing that people
go to the website does ryan kevin look
like harvey weinstein it is universal i
mean the public is confused
you know look at that [ __ ]
anyway that's that
i guess he didn't have that much to say
about it
no the important part again was just
that he savages he's savage he said the
thing he said the thing yeah he said the
thing
he's totally on your side though he
talks a little bit about it afterwards
too that's good i mean how could he how
could you not be
right he made a video recently about
copyright strikes and stuff oh can you
time stamp it let's watch it if he
mentions the thing or does he not
mention it it's about his other way
around he mentions that video while
talking about your lawsuit yo by the way
this is something we've been sitting on
for a while and i swear to god we've
never shown it
and we've been meaning to show this for
so [ __ ] long
so ryan cavanaugh tweeted out this photo
smartest hollywood
[ __ ]
look who's at this damn table
who can point out what's wrong with this
picture
soflo antonio
curtis what's his face who basically is
an r-wordist right he is straight-up
not even debatable nope not to me not to
me at least in the courts so well then
yeah yeah so we got a r wordis we got
soflow we got ray william johnson
if you need more [ __ ] evidence this
guy is a boomer [ __ ] weirdo piece of
[ __ ] look no further
anyone that confers with soulful antonio
on business is a
scam artist pretty much
that's just
use that word you know
and the pro in the proverbial sense of
that so flow's a scam artist
and doing business with it's a joke
basically
scammed i don't actually think that this
is evidence that ryan's doing scams
because he's hitting with subfloor okay
is there any other characters in here i
should know about
this is the seat of power this is the
side of power right here
what why how did ray william johnson get
you're you're stuck at a table between
uh a scammer and an r order what do you
do
jesus
and why are they watching that is that
because that gets me yeah dude you know
it's [ __ ] funny i realized that this
was i was looking at a list of ryan
cavanaugh's biggest flops
oh he's worked on it yeah they paid us a
bunch of money to promote it yeah on our
main channel that was ryan cavanaugh
hey [ __ ] face you paid my ass years ago
a [ __ ] load of money
to promote your dumb ass movie
[Laughter]
god
[Laughter]
yeah actually i know you guys uh rebecca
rebecca's zamolo
she's the blonde i gotcha is there
anything i mean i yeah
what crime did she come in yeah what
does she do she's just like a pretty
vanilla youtuber tick-tocker
where's that article we were reading
about his biggest movie flops because it
was actually super interesting
uh you know where it was it was on
variety
yeah his good friend
relativity media
biggest flops from mastermind to
paranoia
oh yeah
okay this is yeah so this is masterminds
and
so this is super interesting so if you
guys are wondering why relativity media
bankrupted look no further
um well on the first slide of this
actually they point out it's interesting
that you know
we've mentioned that he's famous in
hollywood for coming up with some
algorithm that can predict the success
of films like that was like his claim to
fame
but statistically
it doesn't work like they they have way
more flops than they have brian
kavanaugh i could tell you without even
knowing him just based on what i know
the dude is not a mathematician he's not
a beautiful mind this guy's the only
algorithm he's making is what where can
he the most he can drink uh before
getting pulled over like if you want to
talk about numbers we're talking about
blood alcohol limits you know what i
mean that algorithm didn't work out well
for me no and that and that algorithm
also didn't work so he's no
mathematician twice
yeah so here this this is real good
so here's his biggest flops masterminds
i guess i was part of the flop because
he paid my ass to promote it
they spent
um
let's see
oh not all of them say the budget but
they do say that his his algorithm
predicted it would uh make 125 million
of what knocks up
6.5 stupid ass
some of these are absolutely brutal
the disappointment rooms i think that's
what he calls his living room now
or maybe his bedroom would be would be
funnier
talk about a flop
say what
discord real quick
oh sure
something good or bad
potentially bad
why shouldn't i do that
yeah i'm getting some into live intel
here
bear with us
the disappointments room
um
lived up to its title
it was more than 18 months
and it grossed it open it grows 2.4
million dollars in 18 months dude
and it costs 15 million dollars to make
that ain't nothing
yo this movie he made
made a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
at the box office guys
imagine being ryan cavanaugh making a
whole damn movie and it makes it it
grosses 150 000. the desert dancer i
don't need an algorithm to tell you
nobody watching this [ __ ]
i'll be your algorithm what happened to
soflo
so this one made 1 million bucks
this one
had a 32 million budget it made 26
million
some of these are i'm looking for the
really good ones um
the last one in the list the warriors
way is uh
is pretty juicy when it comes to lost
this one
[ __ ]
romeo and julia
let's see made seven million dollars on
a
35 million dollar budget that is just
doo doo that's a flap that's just being
a shitty at your job bro
um
machine gun preacher this was one of the
really bad ones okay y'all
this one had a 30 million dollar budget
it made half a million dollars
i need a machine gun how's that for
[ __ ] movie production
oh look at the title you know it's dog
[ __ ] machine gun preacher
it's like that's just you read the title
and you say this movie sucks
okay let's read the reviews for machine
gun preacher
oh actually not bad
i guess let's
wait if somebody buys this he who i
guess he brian doesn't get paid his
debtors
you know yeah uh relativity got bought
out after their second bankruptcy yes so
the warriors way was uh
okay
it made uh
it cost six million to make or no cost
42 million dollars to make
and it took in
5.7 million so shout outs to this movie
producing legend
all right enough with cav cav
joel austin not a friend of the show
we hate joel osteen here
we do look at this legend i don't like
it keep with joel wilson
hey man you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
right
you know right
right come on yeah you never meet you
you know right
yeah
yeah
take care folks
he knows
yeah he doesn't know actually i think he
does now
hey man you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
right
you know
actually what's so crazy about joel
austin is that have you heard the story
about the plumber like no such a crook
some plumber was doing work in a
bathroom at his mega church
and he opened a hole in the wall and
there was like millions of dollars in
cash hidden in the wall of joel austin's
mega church six hundred thousand oh six
hundred thousand dollars in cash can
somebody [ __ ] explain uh why god is
stashing cash
well so what's interesting the walls was
that they they
got uh
robbed for a bunch of cash and checks by
the way it was checks too
uh that they found in the wall and just
a few years prior they had reported that
a bunch of it had been stolen um
and so
oh that is high level crimes my friend
that's straight up
i'd call that uh
i call that uh embezzling
yeah thank you
that's talk about prosperity gospel
man jesus is so good to me i got money
in my walls [ __ ]
i'll tell you what man where's the cube
can you go find the cube
okay
what did you realize we just played what
did you say about hiding casually let's
consult the cube yeah what are we going
to do
i tell you what you old peasants come
and give me your money
and i hide it in my walls
[Music]
that's good
y'all give me your money
and i [ __ ] pretended stolen
hide it in my walls for a rainy day
for a really rain for really rainy days
i lock the church and don't let anybody
come in
they could perish in the flood
oh [ __ ]
did we give one to trisha
uh
that might be the one that might be the
one that was uh patricia the last
vestige of our friendship
is a joel austin cube because she loves
joel lostin yeah she's maybe she treats
him all the time maybe this will change
her opinion of him because i don't know
how to spin hiding cash in the wall
all right let's see joe austin this is
joel osteen he makes a prayer cube
which we bought
pre-loaded with prayer
joel what
do we say about hiding six hundred
thousand dollars in cash in the wall go
ahead please
go ahead
joel
draw you there we have to deal with
things that come to an end
we lost our main client a friend we
could always count on is moving away or
a loved one went to be with the lord
we've seen god's blessing in the past we
know we have his favor amen but it seems
like that favor has been taken away amen
but god will never remove something
unless it's six hundred thousand cash
if he didn't stop certain things we
would never get out
[Applause]
we would stay with what's familiar
so sometimes
god shut the [ __ ] up you're so boring
dude
this cube sucks that's the thing it
sucks it's boring should maybe
crack that thing open to see if there's
a thank you okay
i was hoping it'd be more like those
remember those sound boards you get as a
kid where they may like fart and bug and
booger sounds it's hoping to be more
like that yeah that would be funner
booger fart
a yak back remember yak back maybe
that's what it was a yak pack yak back
why back because it would yak back at
you oh yeah come back all right yak back
at me joel
the lord said to me
the government is going to take my money
[Music]
and i had a vision from god himself he
said joel
take that money
hide it in the dry walls
hide it from the devil
hide it from the infidels from the poor
from the homeless from the addicted
fill your walls with unmarked cash
[Music]
the lord said joel
get passports and fake ids
a one-way ticket to thailand where you
can partake in all worldly desires that
are not legal here in america
amen
amen and i said lord i shall obey and
i've got 20 million dollars in cash
stacked in these damn walls and now
y'all wonder why i don't let people in
here when it floods i want them fumbling
to my cash
speared to
death this mega church ain't just a
place of prayer it's my piggy bank
i literally shake you all upside down
and take every penny in your pockets
amen amen can i get an amen amen
the israelis
what
now come on here now come now come on
everyone through my lobby now okay uh we
have atms we got the chair we got the uh
cube here now get out that cash and make
sure to make a good offering for us here
not today
amen that's the lobby of our mega church
look what's on the screen
yeah i put it there oh yeah yeah
you know and and we're adding a new
feature it's a drop box that goes
straight into our drywall you just put
the cash right in there save me the
effort there
now don't tell nobody either
the good thing is we don't report our
income to the government because we're
your church
this is the blood of god
i'm actually hiding it from my partner
because i don't want to share it
man it's crazy how many homeless people
and cold people come out here asking for
handouts man [ __ ] you [ __ ] get your own
mega church
did you hear that the um
oh i right i think we were going to talk
about on leftovers but we didn't get to
it that the second biggest televangelist
in the world one of these guys like joel
osteen who was super anti-vaxx
um was basically just using his his
preaching to just say don't get the
vaccine cope it's fake and everything he
died of uh kovit
the lord took me early
oops
i prayed for that i said lord if i'm
gonna come see you i want to come see
you soon
[Laughter]
he made good on that promise
marcus lamb
i am god's lamb and it was time for me
to shepherd me home boy
here let's watch this how is it so is
joel austin going to jail like i mean
what the [ __ ] is this this is
developments in a store i mean
tracking for years now hundreds of
thousands of dollars reported missing
from lakewood church
may have been found
in a bathroom wall of the church
i believe and the claim made on a radio
show is raising eyebrows all over
houston we're talking about a six
hundred thousand dollars
did any of you watch the show the
righteous gemstones i did no
literally what happened in the show
that somebody accident they were
embezzling a bunch of the donations and
like stashing it in the building and
yeah they did like a big thing
i think joel was watching that show i
was like that's a that's a great idea
that's a really good idea you should
watch that show ethan it's fantastic i
just found an article and like the first
sentence mentions the righteous
gemstones yeah it seems like awesome i
haven't seen it since it came hey those
righteous gemstones guys got some good
ideas
i wanna believe it i believe that
you know what i like to do i like to
hollow out my big cross with christ on
it you know and i stack the hundreds in
there nobody think to look at the cross
you know
that's just holy
you can't touch it you can't knock it
[ __ ] even the feds won't even touch that
[ __ ] you know they are superstitious
like
so i stack it with the hundreds
i put the i put the diamonds in it the
chicks
yay brother
i forgot about that one the guy that
just gets lazy in the middle of his uh
joel osteen's basement by the way
all right this is the basement of the
mega church looks like yeehaw brothers
this morning
rochelle this is just simply wow pretty
unbelievable
like i'm not i'm not i have nothing
wrong with faith and religion i think
it's fine but organized religion they're
all criminals sorry they're all
criminals or worse i mean
narrow edge okay
organizers make an exception
go ahead everybody that we talk about on
this show they're organized yeah
everybody that we talk about on the show
at least as far as these these grifter
preachers and everything they're all
part of the same subset of prosperity
gospel evangelicalism which is
well your criticism of the catholic
church is very different yeah line of
attack um they also get a lot of money i
won't i mean you see those gold crowns
those [ __ ] i mean that's basically just
that stuff and money fair enough but
just saying
all organized religion that's that's a
pretty name a good one
well i mean
there's lots of them i mean name one
then
uh
lutherans are pretty cool
lutherans yeah not anything about the
lutheran well then
lutheran scandals and watch lutherans
are going to end up being really bad too
but i i don't know i was just
you know i hear
it's a relatively progressive um uh
christianity all right we love the
lutherans what about the jedis
the jedis yeah dude the jedis are
[ __ ] freaks bro they're like
religious zealots that like
killed a certain point of
view [ __ ] the jedi
also i heard they [ __ ] kids but i think
anything is it
i do think that any
uh church that you know is encouraging
um political takes and stuff should
should obviously get slammed with uh i'm
not seeing much about the lutherans here
don't see much at the top lutheran
scandal i mean that's good right that
means there's no scandal yeah
lutheran pastor accused of abuse well
that i mean it's going to happen i mean
lutheran church abuse victims receive 70
million settlement okay well fair enough
the lutherans are bad
[Laughter]
not the lutherans but you know there's a
spectrum for for all these things and um
organized religion sets a
it sets a framework okay where
that basically enables any bad actor to
come in and work within that framework
and avoid scrutiny
and accountability
under the guise of religion where they
can steal money
commit heinous acts of of
uh essay
and you know it happens in any framework
of organized religion because the way we
treat
religion in this country
as uh you know the sacred institution
that we can't scrutinize the federal
government the police whatever
um it's just it's like a framework that
is just set up to do evil and you know i
think the people who make them have good
have good intentions and there's lots of
good people within the faiths obviously
as always um but
you know what i'm saying the framework
itself
is just uh
don't do good work man i mean i'm sorry
i wasn't paying attention yeah so all
good delete me from this conversation
you know sound bite
yeah i know just making sure
am i getting cancelled in the comments
no i don't think so not yet no it's you
know you're far from alive it's
interesting that i mean i don't attend
church i'm not uh a member of i'm i'm an
agnostic but um i'm just wary of of
throwing all organized religion under
the same umbrella i think some are
clearly
way worse than others i just think it's
a problem with framework it really is
like there's no accountability i mean
look what the [ __ ] accountable god baby
yeah well
when that exactly when you're
accountable to god you have [ __ ] uh
psychopaths who don't believe in god and
you know can run amok and do whatever
the [ __ ] they want
also doesn't accountability to god
doesn't do much
in christianity when you can pretty much
get absorbed for literally any crime as
long as you're like jeez we mean jesus
is good
like that's what cr i don't know
christianity's like g
uh jesus died for my sins and that
includes stealing money from y'all
or you know essaying your children jesus
died for me
you'd be like surprised to hear that i
see some good takes
you do see good comments in the chat
yeah there's a spectrum of everything i
just think the people that use it for
the wrong reasons who use religion for
money or whatever are the most evil vile
[ __ ] in the world they don't
give a [ __ ] but they're they're other
people good religious organizers i mean
the church that i
grew up in uh is
called unitarian universalist church and
google them
and it was a it's like a hyper
progressive super hippy dippy church and
i'm not a member anymore
my parents were and that's that's what i
went to growing up but a big part of it
is they did a lot of interfaith outreach
kind of stuff and so when i was a kid
and in like the religious education
classes or whatever we'd go visit other
religions
churches or temples or whatever
you know we went to like hindu temples
and and stuff like that as well catholic
churches and
you know there's a there's a whole
spectrum out there and a lot of them are
not as bad they're not all joel osteen
that's all that's all i'm saying well i
don't know much about like the
corruption within eastern religions i'll
be honest with that about like you know
the buddhism or hinduism or whatever the
[ __ ]
other ones they practice but
christianity and what you see here and
judaism
is disgustingly corrupt i mean just
disgustingly corrupt and
all right
you know what i'm saying
i
i do i do
whoa girl what's up
okay let's listen to her what the [ __ ]
is this that cam just like what drip
you've been looking at oh yeah look at
this drip bro i mean what the [ __ ]
exactly
that that yeah
what level uh white mage you think he is
that's level 90 that's a 90 yeah
that's raid gear bro
yeah these guys don't even have to hide
money in the walls i mean what the [ __ ]
he just wears millions on his back
all right
wow
crazy can you believe it oh my gosh
really yes that is what many people are
going to be thinking once they watch
this story
it's funny coming in out of that without
any context
yeah we need a sound bit of that wow
crazy crazy
can you believe it
who heard the claim this morning
rochelle this is just simply a wow
pretty unbelievable
christine andy wow
crazy can you believe it oh my gosh
really yes that is what many people are
going to be thinking once they watch
this story a plumber just doing his job
at lakewood church discussions
it was the craziest phone call we've
ever had wow crazy
[ __ ] this story broke on a radio show
the plumber called into the radio show
like i got a story to tell you all
that's funny
for the morning bullpen at 100.3 the
bowl it's the greatest job ever this
morning
a call from a plumber who recently did
some work at lakewood church there was a
loose toilet in the wall and
we removed the tile they removed the
tile
i went to go remove the toilet and move
some insulation away and
about
500 envelopes fell out of the wall
and i was like oh wow wow
that means that that upstairs right
above that bathroom
your boy joel
has a little drop box under the
floorboard
little slit between two tiles yeah that
he's been making deposits in
and he they opened the insulation a
little bit and bob's your uncle oh lord
i may i have made it the uh depa i've
sown my seed
that's what they say right
so your seed
after someone stole
six hundred thousand dollars obviously
this case remains under investigation
seven years later a man fixing a toilet
at the church discovered money in the
wall i went ahead and contacted the
maintenance supervisor that was there
and i went ahead and turned it off again
lakewood church
recently while repair work was being
done at lakewood church an undisclosed
amount of cash and checks were found
lakewood immediately notified the
houston police department and is
assisting them with their
stolen investigation ago and the money
found by the plumber are related but
lindsay says investigators would have
never known about the money if it wasn't
for the plumber who discovered it
there's still a lot of questions
if it's that money why did they never go
back and get that money it's like i said
it's like a movie i really think i can
make a 10 you want to know why the
burglars went never went back got the
money
there was no burglar
you know right
yeah you know
take care folks
that last year yeah it's so good
hey man you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
right
you know right
right
what's his house look like joel
he probably got one of these like 60
million dollar house which one joel
osteen house let's see
oh my [ __ ] god i had i had no idea
what to expect here's his house
you see that healing
holy [ __ ] literally the righteous
gemstones
yo look at that house dude
i wonder if danny mcbride has ever
specified who uh
the main inspiration for that show was
because i wouldn't be surprised i mean
who's who's better than it was either
austin or
uh copeland for sure how much did that
thing cost i mean it's in texas
obviously that looks pricey though so
expensive yeah texas is not yeah
actually not much cheaper 10 million oh
wow
damn 10 million
texas holy [ __ ] he probably bought that
house a long ass time ago though and it
gets muggy down there in houston oh yeah
oh yeah it does
until it gets hot in texas
17 000 square feet on two acres
what in god's [ __ ] do you need 17 000
square feet for a lot of money to hide
he owns a private jet of course
he's they they estimate his net worth
around 100 million
and 600 000 that was in the walls
um
fantastic eh
we love this man god pays good
god pays very good
and the benefits are incredible
so shout outs to joel austin
speaking of prosperity zack you got one
of your seeds uh
brought brought fruit and forth uh they
did they did uh with the help of you uh
kraft sent me a check for a hundred
bucks can you hear that eli
did you see they sent him a fake gift
card no they sent him a 100 gift card
that didn't work oh and so we chat we
called them out so
what happened with that was when you
they were they message me and they're
like yeah it says on our end the gift
card was working i've tried it at
countless different stores and the
[ __ ] car didn't work all right
it says on the account online that
there's a hundred bucks in there but the
card they sent me was defective
so
and then they're like okay we're gonna
make right by this so they sent me a
check for a hundred dollars
i gotta say i'm i'm proud of them we
yeah they they endured a lot of sl of uh
you know hellman slander oh boy did they
yeah
um so yeah thank you craft mayonnaise so
what are you going to spend that on
mayonnaise now because you're supposed
to yeah
you're going to buy hemantics with that
i'm going to get hellman's
that's dirty after they made good
what can i say well [ __ ] savage
almonds taste better
oh [ __ ]
mask off now now that you got the money
did you catch the check because they can
still cancel it i did cash okay good
they'll be cancelling that [ __ ] if you
didn't yeah i know
actually i got to give a quick shout out
to our members thank you to everybody
who's a member
you get episodes a day early for example
leftovers will be coming up for you on
saturday sunday and exciting news is our
bts
uh we're making a bts every week hosted
by ab
uh available to our members only and is
this one up already av
it's right it's ready to be posted we
usually post it right after the show
ends okay so there's gonna be a bts
going up right after the show for
members here's a little preview
of the antics you can enjoy
make sure push your butt forward you
don't wanna [ __ ] your back up
[Music]
the boys are hard at work right now
everybody's game
you see
i contributed to society by rocking
and rolling
not playing halo training
oh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she's my jump rope teacher should
aim for something
what did you crash into
people running out of their way
our security guard he's going to
participate in a segment we're doing
do a little taste test how do you feel
swami yeah right i feel different right
now
you can't you can't i don't know i
yeah so if you want to watch my gatsby
my mom on the gatsby if you want to
watch swami uh describing
it's a long one this week too i think
it's almost 20 minutes it's really
around 17 minutes
a longer one so
that is content
so thank you to all of our members yes
there's somebody else we need to think
family
not family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
family family
there's someone else we need to thank
who's that our last two sponsors oh okay
let's let's do that let's do it first we
have hbo max who he loves so well i love
hbo max
either how much do you love hbo max it's
like dude
wow
that's perfect perfect instead
hbo max is keeping our streaming queue
stocked up all year round
and not to mention all the amazing stuff
that's coming out dune amazing love that
movie of many saints of newark
succession season three insecure
season five curb season 11 and the one
i'm most excited about the freaking
matrix i don't know why they're not
including that here i mean it's
definitely on hbo max and it's
definitely coming out this month
dan you're downloading it no it is
i have been watching every sunday i
watch insecure
curb
and now i'm now i'm catching up on
succession too because i
you like that show i i've heard a lot
about it but i i it's good yeah it's so
good i like it now it's like high drama
but it's like one of the really good
drama it's adam mckay right so
depressing
it's funny though like adam
everybody is a bad character
all bad guys yeah
you like your love
yeah i've been enjoying that
very much i mean max came to sweden not
too long ago so finishing that stuff
good hbo just makes the best show oh you
know what else is on hbo max what
righteous gemstones oh there you
freaking go by the way matrix
resurrection comes out on hbo max
december 22nd i mean
hello
hello hello hello
that's our last episode that day oh [ __ ]
i gotta watch it at 12 then
i was just gonna say let's just cancel
the last episode no we all watched
episode 12 and watch it
hbo max has all your favorite titles
available for streaming they got
something for everyone which you know
everyone's going to love it and it's all
in one place you can download top titles
to watch your device to go don't miss
out on taking your entertainment game to
the next level hbo max is the streaming
home of over 13 000 hours of addictive
series blockbuster movies
and exclusive original start streaming
on your favorite device today sign up
now at hbom
dot a x slash h3 after dark they have
the worst url
once again and the links in the
description so
don't you don't have to write it down
hbo m dot a x slash h3 after dark
my favorite streaming platform i have to
say that and thank you zach
we stand zach for saying that
and liquid iv another a beautiful
sponsor we love liquid iv
taking that hydration to the next level
dan is demonstrating you take the pack
you put it in a nice couple of fresh
water or sewage water i mean whatever
you like or water that's been sitting
here for a couple hours since before the
show
not sun
it's just water make it sound like it
expired or something like it's meat that
you left out rotten
what flavor did you put in there
i think it's passion fruit yes it is
it's passion fruit yeah so what i love
about liquid iv is basically you know
sometimes coffee is really hard on my
stomach you can get the caffeine formula
you can get the
relax or the
focus formula
you can get the hydration formula the
the immune boost formula one is uh this
is the hydration with powered by
cellular transport technology that's ctt
c2t
um
you know one stick of liquid iv 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water
they got great flavors watermelon
strawberry lemon lime
and you're gonna love it
so
you know if you're in the morning before
a workout when you feel run down you
feeling dehydrated you're hungover
liquid iv rules for it all
and it's got great taste
it's easy to use it's low impact you
don't get a huge plastic bottle it comes
in these little pouches you know it's
less wasteful
they donate a bunch of uh of liquid iv
they donated over 11 million sticks to
people around the world
[ __ ] hell bro
they've got lemon lime strawberry
watermelon passion fruit guava pina
colada or immune support and tangerine
um they can so hydrated it contains five
essential vitamins more vitamin c than
an orange as much potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and it's made with clean ingredients
non-gmo vegan free of gluten dairy and
soy no soboy's allowed
grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 15
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code h3 at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using the promo code h3
liquidity.com thank you
all right
hey
hey
oh this is pretty funny
um
you might want to play some sad music
for this one
you just said it was funny
it is fun both funny and
it is both funny oh my god shredder's so
comfortable
i didn't know we had a shredder
[Music]
shred alex's ear scratch though
cute legend
wow
wow
wow
oh wow man
[Music]
all right
yeah here's keemstar he's trying to be a
serious reporter
he says i'm about to interview jake paul
what do you want me to ask him
now when you first of all when you hear
someone say i'm about to interview
someone what is that what do you think
that means ila
[Music]
what does that mean to you say i'm about
to interview jake paul what would you
expect to happen
that it's about to happen
or what a what interview yeah about to
talk to the guy yeah okay so he follows
up an hour later they didn't call on me
in the press conference
ah i never got asked anything
[Laughter]
he's too [ __ ] washed up for even jake
paul
and it was like just part of a press
conference yeah and they didn't even
call on him that's not interviewed jack
jackpot no
they didn't even [ __ ] notice his ass
in there
it's awesome
wow
it's pretty sad like like i mean that's
pretty good right he's a big said
big lmi
the king of self-report doesn't
disappear he really is the king well he
[ __ ] himself by hyping this up again
and then he had to do something what a
dish
i have several questions
person running the press conference
keemstar shut up
anytime i feel like a painfully awkward
loser i remind myself that i'll never be
as bad as keem and i'm good again
that should give us all hope
another friend
so frustrated
another friend of the show garyvee
we talked about v's nfts about that [ __ ]
was selling like crazy his little napkin
scribbles
and uh well love you're a fan what do
you think about this [ __ ]
sorry i was doing something else
watch this i've done 91 million dollars
in revenue
the first 51 million i kept
which was in one week
the
[Music]
the next 40
i've gotten a 10 royalty on every
transaction
last night while i was sleeping i made
246 000
on the royalties of people selling my
nfts to each other i don't believe it i
didn't know why i hate to say it but i
think this might actually be true based
on
if you go to his website it it these
people are buying you have you not seen
these no
okay
i had i don't want to re-litigate the
whole thing but you got to see what he's
selling as his nft
v friends what the [ __ ] is it called
yeah
this i [ __ ] you not he's making his own
art mom mom
i call her mom at all
oh [ __ ]
it's not loading what happened to your
website garyveefriend
here and this is his [ __ ] here this
is a forty thousand dollar
drawing of a llama that he drew either
and you can
and then you can see
there's a video of him creating it
okay so so this is all real and you can
see the sales on the blockchain really
yeah
why
dude i don't know
i don't so he said he made 90 million
dollars in 90 days dan
what do we think about this i don't
believe it
are you serious he's trying to prove the
point he's trying to prove that the
value is in the ownership whether you
agree or not
but
no but that's that that point doesn't
make sense because
nobody would if he doodled on a real
piece of paper
nobody would [ __ ] pay
for example this one
two hundred thousand dollars for well
people have been doodling on papers for
millions of years but and if these are
new
so you know new tech
yeah and on a paper sorry but if if you
sign your name on a paper or if i sign
my name on a paper they'd be worth
different and
it'd be worth less i'm yeah well i'm
saying
with the blockchain you can't use it
anymore you can't print anything on that
doesn't make sense why would the
physical copy be work worth less
well because it's it could get damaged
that's the whole thing with the nfts is
that it's backed up on the block can you
get damaged i mean um hello well if
you're drawing pieces are but that's
what he's trying to prove he's trying to
prove that nfts have value in them
because of ownership and that they're
backed up on the blockchain do i agree
with nfts and all that i'm not saying
that but that's the point he's trying to
but i don't think i think anyone who's
actually buying this [ __ ] is people who
are like embed or like doing uh
financial crimes i swear to god the only
people that have this much ethereum to
spend are like the rubeck guy and they
just collect these things to [ __ ]
embezzle money to hide money launders
probably to launder money to like i'm
i'm just nobody nobody who isn't just
getting shady ethereum is spending two
hundred thousand dollars on this [ __ ]
drawing and i just remember you know
i'm sorry but garyvee is not a genius
for this it's
maybe he is i don't know i wouldn't i
wouldn't i mean i mean it's it's
humiliating this this is this is
this is called the collapse of society
just like all the other videos you see
but supposedly there's a corrupt file
yeah he didn't draw he didn't even prove
that he drew this one maybe
he's like hey guys here's my llama
drawing he didn't even even draw it well
when the next person flips it i mean
it's links back to his wallet love has
done it where he's bought nfts right
love where you flipped him where he's
had him for a short amount of time he's
made great pogba yeah but that's that's
just a that's just called like a
that's just a ponzi scheme isn't it when
you hope to sell to the next guy for
less and that's its own and that's all
the intrinsic value that it is
well what's your point like i think both
me and abe agrees it's kind of dumb it's
totally dumb yes but we're just trying
to explain why it's happening yes
i understand that donation doesn't make
sense but i would why are there so many
people that would be willing to drop two
hundred thousand dollars on something
i'll tell you why does that make sense
the only explanation is that there's
lots of shady people that have lots of
ethereum from doing shady [ __ ] yeah boom
that's it you know every time there's a
market that kind of blows up
there's like always dumb people who's
going to have a lot of money like tesla
has been blowing up like
there's a bunch no that's not the same
tesla's a public
tesla
back in the days only weird and dumb
people
like got into cryptos right it was a
weirdos so now they're doing weird [ __ ]
it's rich weirdos having money i don't
know yeah
bro i'm telling you these crypto
millionaires are all shitty as [ __ ] yeah
they're all super weird but they just
bought the cheap this is rhubarb this is
faze blanks this is this is the [ __ ]
they're buying
i'm just saying they're a weirdo just
saying back here matt who the [ __ ] is
this
colin burrs who the [ __ ] is colin burrs
how do we look up his wallet because
apparently this guy's buying a shitload
of tokens
who the [ __ ] is calling burns
he's on twitter
i gotta sell
an nft was nine months ago i'm sorry but
gary's just getting a nice slice of
rhubarb money is what i the way i see
this
but what i did when i understood
something was brewing is in the height
of my business
when i have a trillion things going on
while i'm trying to navigate nine
billion other businesses i'm meditating
on i just spent 50 hours learning what
nfts were
i had to take a break i was so busy i
couldn't even imagine killing my whole
family that night really upset it really
threw my whole day off
well the top comment is people realizing
gary's just another snake oil salesman
so that's interesting
i would like someone to do a deep dive
on this v friends thing and examine the
wallets who are buying this [ __ ] i
wonder who these [ __ ] people are i
want to know how many people are buying
this [ __ ] you know what i mean it's all
anonymous
no but you can you can look at the
crypto wall and see is this crypto
wallet buying and selling how many do
they own
what else are they involved in you know
what i mean like you won't have a name
on it but
most nft wallets
are kind of public now because they
connected so much stuff like openc and
they connect their social media so it's
super easy to check out like most nft
world well there you go
yeah i would love love love to
know who the [ __ ] are these
dumb [ __ ] bro
look at this
goo it says goo on it why does it say
goo on it
last sale was 48 ethereum
that'd be 220 000 yeah i don't buy that
i don't either i'm sorry i don't i just
don't but something is weird here and
gary i believe gary's making the money
but
something's [ __ ] weird with this i'm
sorry it just doesn't make sense
i don't care who's sipping for gary who
thinks he's like a genius who's just
like bro i doubt that you don't make 90
million dollars you reach people in his
audience no impossible can drop that
money people watch garyvee because
they're broke exactly people watch
garyvee because they want to be rich
rich people don't watch garyvee i
guarantee you that a lot of successful
people go into his office for uh
consulting and social media and stuff
yeah guess what they're not doing buying
his nfts [ __ ] guarantee it you find
me proof that one wealthy friend of his
bought one of these stupid [ __ ]
things and i'll eat my hat unless
they're in on it together and they're
buying it to inflate it that's what i'm
saying we need to examine the wallets
who's buying this [ __ ] because that
happens that happens a lot yeah exactly
people buy like there was this huge
headline like an nft sold for or ape
sold for a quarter billion dollars and
then when you and it was this huge
headline and then when you actually look
at the blockchain it was like a flash
loan where they bought it and then
returned the money and like no so no it
didn't really sell for that you know
i'm sorry guys but this is not [ __ ]
normal
reselling stuff that you were talking
about was crypto punks if you go to this
website you can see the crazy prices
they
they go for where'd you send it on
discord yeah on discord yeah yeah i mean
i know crypto punks like this this one
is well established and i understand the
collectibility of it
the garyvee one uh the v friends is
super [ __ ] stupid and weird though
right there you got the sets i mean this
one
current lowest price wow 270.
number of sales in the past 12 months 12
000.
total value of all sales 1.7 billion
total creators of
the punks made five percent of that
mama maybe
yeah
what is that like uh what's that end up
being
five percent difference is astronomical
damn
what's five percent of a billion i mean
five mil i mean five million five
percent or no 50 million
so they made almost 100 million
yep
but how much did they originally sell
them for like for the first sale were
they cheap
um
i don't know actually early early on
they probably were but um yeah that
one's has a lot of attention so that guy
on this is one of the ones which it's
dumb i think it's dumb as hell but like
i understand the collectibility and i
see everyone talking about so this one's
super hyped up
but
v friends is not that
kavish
i mean
i mean this [ __ ] is dumb too
though i'm sorry just it's so dumb
once a day genuinely sit there for five
minutes and make pretend one of them got
shot in the face
no i'm not doing that garyvee
you try to find me an example of one of
his rich friends binding one of his dumb
[ __ ] napkin doodles they don't do it
you know here's something garyvee does
do on his free time i can guarantee you
that
makes out with his dad
yeah i'm at the nfts
natural
[Applause]
have you did you see the zealot forget
yeah i lose track of what shows we did
without you
yeah well some of it i listened to so
we're definitely playing with fire with
the garyvee goofs though because i know
a lot of people love his ass some of
them in this office
[Music]
rich people do not go to garyvee for
advice they're all they're rich people
that go to self-help are people that
want to be rich and successful i don't
know him well enough i'm just trying to
say his point but what i do know of him
i mean i do have some respect from
i don't know much but i seen him on joe
rogan like four years ago and everything
he said joe rogan's like you're wrong
you're stupid you sound ridiculous right
now there's no way and almost everything
he predicted on that show came true
within four years time
huh yeah like
what i have to go watch the show
you don't remember a single one it was
that impressive i am going to scam 90
million away from my fans in the next
four years by selling them no way
doodles on napkins
that would be amazing if he actually
pretty much nobody believed him yet he
did it here we are can you cut to my
screen ian
yeah
yeah i'm into nfd so what
yeah so what
i'm into nfts
you remember him talking about tick tock
long before his massive i mean that's
not that revolutionary [ __ ] vine was
huge before tick tock and musically
it's not like it was nothing damn the
guy's right about one thing you gotta
suck his dick forever
[ __ ] i've been right about [ __ ] i'm
always right
i'm right
what's something i've been right about
kovitz
yeah
you were right about cover i bet garyvee
was saying it's just a cold he's the
type of dude to be like it's just a cold
let me google that i bet you his ass
said that
yeah look you fact check that
all those guys are like it's just a cold
this is gonna be the ultimate test
because if you're wrong about this he's
wrong about everything
go ahead
i'm looking i'm looking
fine garyvee let's
see this is huge
we're getting to the bottom of this
this might take a minute i don't know if
you wanna i'm way insiders i don't wait
for this chat might have something good
too here let me go to chat the ultimate
test
let's see the gazebo zone gary be the
type to catch cover and sell it
he sort of did
he has a bunch of videos about how to
hustle your way through the pandemic
for real yeah love that for him
love that for him
which one is your favorite drawing ela
if you had to pick buy one
[Music]
the friends teddy fresh collab coming
soon the thing is like
you can buy from a famous artist a
beautiful piece
this is what guys really think about
this okay
i mean genuinely think about this
you could buy like an original
art piece from uh
we went to that show in l.a it was like
virgil and takashi and takashi collab
yeah you could buy an original art piece
from takashi and virgil
for less than these nfts do you
understand
what the [ __ ] i'm saying
it was probably like a hundred thousand
for the original yeah
okay
so you could have an original takashi
or you could have this [ __ ] worm
that's not even physical
it doesn't seem like garyvee was very uh
anti
uh
covet or anything oh this is a really
interesting uh
insight from headset ablaze garyvee is a
televangelist for capitalism
that's kind of an interesting analogy
isn't it
i mean
don't we love that
televangelist for crypto bros it's kind
of [ __ ] interesting
you know
yeah i'm sorry i'm not finding any uh
garyvee anti-vaxx or
anything like that
sorry it's out there someone will find
it sorry what is this dan you want to
give a shout out to this tick tock
account
huh
to the madashi boys
oh my dashie boy my dashie boy is my boy
have you seen these
i love
[ __ ] there's an airplane coming
he's so [ __ ] badass dude watch this
whoa
no way
watch out i love that guy just casually
no
wings from his head
wait
i don't think wings sprout from your
head
did you
i mean
you just saw the video no i saw the
video so what are you talking about
you're right it happened so why question
it wow
that was cool i love madishi boy he is
that was awesome i'd buy that as an st
for sure
that to me is more interesting that's
more valuable yeah
okay so same location
[Music]
oh [ __ ] excuse me
oh so that time he put the wings on his
back so that was that was a interesting
wait so he's on a he is a helicopter
he's not on a helicopter yeah
yeah and he's ascending to heaven
so yeah because here's the propellers he
is a helicopter
love that
madeshi
boy
here comes another one this one looks
real spooky crazy intense
we got the helicopter
we got it there's so many stages
now wait now you think he's going to
take out the helicopter but hold on
bring it back bring it back yeah oh and
then split it
the guy i mean he's got a plan it's kind
of interesting you know he he he scripts
this stuff
yeah pretty high level he's going to
turn into a
turn into a tiger
whoa dude
split it and crush it look at that it's
interesting that he chooses of all
weapons the
most deadly comes to mind the tire yeah
it's like it's a running theme in a lot
of his tick tocks actually of him taking
out evil doers with tires he's like
magneto but he controls rubber right
which actually would be pretty cool
um and finally from the modashi boys
modeshi 6'9
[Laughter]
my attitude you love me or hate me i
don't care
don't play with me
don't play with me
wait what happened here something real
interesting happened like really fast
what was that he turns into like a like
a gorilla or something for a second or
oh
what does he
what the [ __ ] some sort of saber-tooth
uh is that purple spider-man
no it is some kind of gorilla-esque
purple hybrid saber-toothed tiger
gorilla what the hell
yeah pretty badass you're right yep
you're definitely right i'm trying to
share that with you
boy but nestor boy 2. i haven't figured
out what happened to the original
hostile takeover
oh this was a everyone was begging me to
react to this
apparently there's like a pic
there's a strong pickup
community on tick tock the pickup artist
so
this one's pretty badass apparently
oh
wait for it
oh he cut it she was definitely gonna
fall off his shoulder
shaking and struggling
wait dude he was definitely gonna drop
watch his knees the girl on the left is
about to straight up just fall off yeah
i mean cool like they i guess i don't
know what to tell you so badass yeah
it looks
[Laughter]
so hot
so hot look how he drops her ass
so freaking hot
let's watch more of his
[Music]
wow what do you mean ew he's [ __ ] hot
kind of an interesting effect actually
though what is it it's like x-ray
glasses or something oh yeah let's go a
little lower daddy a little lower
women argument part one
[Music]
okay
a little straight to the neck a little
quickly there huh
no foreplay or anything
oh my god yeah this is pretty trashy eh
a little bit big food
okay one less vulgar please dude i'm
doing a family show here
yeah i don't know how much success
you'll have with les walker on
on this channel i'm afraid
is he dating like nine different girls
i think they're all models and none of
them would actually touch him
it's like the dan blizzarian thing you
know
does he have a lot of followers
uh
some have a lot of views like this one
only has
1200 likes and 30 comments so
like it seems hit and miss for about 1.5
million followers though
you think it's you think it's girls or
boys following the [ __ ] i get this good
question i guess a little of both eh
i mean some some probably follow for the
cringe
no this is all earnest
this is all thirst
that there you go that's that's the true
test right
it's probably just all little boys
that's not big though
got him
it's probably a worrying amount of kids
following him
yeah i would say it's definitely all
kids have um it's bad i have bad news my
back is hurting oh no
is there a way for you not to be on your
elbow is that why or do you think it's
just it's hard to get to the mic
if i'm not you want to hold the mic
would that help but it's like i don't
know
maybe i should go back to a chair you
want to oh let's go back to the chair
yeah yeah all right we can do some uh
some surgery some office surgery
yeah so i think this is kind of a prank
invasion type of situation going on on
tick tock
you know
a little too graphic though for youtube
maybe
bro they should just ban all that kind
of content from tick tock
it's hard though because like what's the
policy because their policy is currently
like
you know
well you've got to recognize there's
like
i guess they're they probably already
have a policy against sexual content and
that definitely is right
yeah
and you only have to be like 13 to use
tick tock
i mean it's not that young
that's i don't know maybe it's not that
bad it's just a little vulgar
i don't know
i mean you shouldn't just go up and
choke women that's probably bad
messaging
oh man we've got the ace family tour and
we've got nicocado to talk about still
that's exciting
which one should we do first maybe
nicocado
here
[Music]
you cue this up
this is from uh
7 000 calorie
joel b feast what is joel b
jollibee
where do you get jollibee it's a
filipino fast food restaurant
really
where can i get that in the video he
asks if you have ever had it
i haven't we'll have so much to talk
about
exactly sam's big jollibee yo can we
order jolly bee
right now
when else
ask lena if it's okay i don't know
it's friday friday gonna get down on
friday well if i've never had joel b
then i deserve then i [ __ ] deserve it
baby [ __ ]
ella you want to try jolly it's a what
where's it from jolly bee oh jelly um
filipino food filipino food
in america and they have spaghetti even
better than taco bell don't they have
like spaghetti with hot dogs in it or
something spaghetti oh that's pretty
dirty
that's like my lazy mom
yeah people say it's so good show it off
no you're ready to go i mean
that baby could live outside you you
know what i mean it's ready
check check
so let's get some some uh
you jolly bee going
and as a as a gesture of goodwill to
nick here
so that when he comes on i can say yes i
have had jolly bee
exactly
what do you think about jollibee hello
do we love that
based on this photo yes no oh either
saying no based on this photo ela can
you move the mic just well let's watch
him eating it yes and talking about
thank you okay
jollibee
i need a jolly bee
it feels so weird to sit here again is
it how's your back does it feel better
like that
um yeah i think so
okay good you like that we're like a
nascar team
is that we're like a nascar team like
actually what i think the bed was better
yeah
yeah
move it back
all right here let's see what the nick
says so yeah you guys should be happy to
know
we've had some
um internal negotiating going on
we've been haggling a little bit on the
conditions i'll be honest
i say this with peace and love he's a
little bit of a diva
[Laughter]
i've interviewed a-list celebrities on
this show yeah
[Music]
i've never
had some of the requests
on me that he's made
but he is superstar yeah i mean he is a
superstar that and we love him we're
interested in him we want him here
so we have reached terms we have reached
an agreement for him to come in january
i genuinely am excited to interview nick
i find him fascinating i find him funny
actually
um i
don't
i just i want to talk to him i i feel
like i have so much to learn from him
right
and his
story and uh i'm super excited so we're
we're taking a break when we come back
from january we have
um we're going to have him back we're
going to have him on so super excited we
just got to nail down the date so yeah
it's going to be awesome it's going to
be fun i think we'll get on well i think
we'll get along
[Applause]
that's not for now
this is for you ethan thank you bro
i want it
lately is there anything on my face he
keeps talking about how hungry he is
i don't know if hildy's letting him eat
but it'll be
this is for you
oh yeah that looks good dude that crunch
is loud
all right we're getting jill we're
getting jolly
we're getting we're getting it you know
i actually on his instagram he put up a
poll of if we wanted him to eat krispy
kreme or jollibee i clicked jollibee
how close was the vote
i'm pretty sure
jolly be like one by a little it eased
out a little bit huh he did yeah he did
krispy kreme can we get a menu for ella
to see if there's something that she i
don't want anything from there oh [ __ ]
let's eat us out we gotta get something
else you can get something else for me
eela's out sorry guys sorry uh yeah i
think uh
i mean then i don't see anything here
you're right
yeah i don't think i
let's get together and have some
jollibee yeah have it for the first time
you know what i'll go toe to toe with
you bro you wanna mukbang me oh we'll
listen you don't have anything
you have a kid on the way to that yeah
toe to toe baby no
i wanna get him out here wait i need to
negotiate the terms too
the terms of my eating limits you're
gonna have to talk me down a little bit
all right my my attorney's gonna have to
go over the the terms of this uh nick
sorry hildy has a say in this
this is for you you ethan
thank you bro
look at that that was all skin dude
ethan
what are we gonna eat
he said he'd do a mukbang with me yeah
well
okay
i need to give him something really
really i was asking olivia because she's
an avid fan or follower
okay hold on he said sorry zach he said
i'm gonna do a mukbang with him but i'm
paying him
so he better pay my ass if he wants me
to do a mukbang with him no it's for
for the point i assumed that it would oh
i was like i'll do one on his channel
that's what i mean
we can mukbang together though yeah on
the show for sure i think when you
interview him you guys should be eating
but you're saying if he wants a video on
his channel he needs to pay you
definitely
and my rate's double whatever i pay him
yeah we should do a mukbang at some
point point in the show
yes yeah
yeah
great i'll let him decide what
this chicken okay so
i'm just like
i have reasons which i don't want to go
into on camera
and then i have other reasons which i
also don't want but then there's also
things too um i just
i'm getting too fat to like transport
that's amazing i'm not i'm not even
trolling i'm not being funny
i don't think you real well no one
realizes except the people who watch my
first video here
get in here
wrecked my body for three days now
obviously there's a major time zone
difference i think going to
is it yeah la's the same time zone as me
so it won't be time zone difference it's
just i physically can't do anything
anymore i'm literally gonna be on my 600
pound life
this is what i'm saying
yes i will literally push him through
the airport if he wants
he just has to exist i'll do all the
pushing i won't look at him he doesn't
want me to look at him no eye contact no
eye contact i won't say a word i was
asking olivia if he eats all the food
that's on the table in his videos and
she said no he eats a lot of it he eats
what he can and then and then he's done
i don't think it's humanly possible to
eat all the food he lays out he does his
darndest yeah but he does a pretty good
job
he seems like he's happy with the
the gaining weight right yes so
interesting i yes it's super interesting
and it has no problem with the fact that
like even transporting himself is an
issue
no
i don't think so that's what i'm so it's
so interesting to me
what like i don't know i'm just
captivated by this guy he's he's just
he's [ __ ] fascinating
bring the gatsby to the airport people
are saying
that is what i said
i will give him the gatsby
bro we should mobility scooter your ass
around
there's a hunger for this character to
come back
i saw him dancing around he looked
pretty pretty nimble to me he was
dancing on the beach
you guys say i'm fat i can still travel
i can still [ __ ] no you take a trip
fair point you're not fat
you always saying i'm just as fat as
dick like we were wrong but it's not
what we thought
yes there was one particular video when
he like stood up and stood sideways and
his belly didn't seem that big yeah then
in the other videos we saw i was like he
weighed in at 360 bro yeah that's that's
pretty big yeah come on now
dream come true
i'll go toe-to-toe though
oh my goodness dude
the hardest part about coming here was
walking through the airport
i was so sore so my legs have blown up
holy [ __ ] my eyes felt like uh
so that's what i'm interested it's like
well do you want to lose weight or you
want to keep gaining weight and
are you worried about like
the consequences is it like a self-harm
thing like i i don't know i mean i i i
don't know
i'm so [ __ ] interested and not in a
judgmental way like you know and just
from a human standpoint he's a
fascinating whatever's going on here is
fascinating
i find that really fascinating um
yeah real quick
should sam order a shitload of that
fried chicken no no they we need
something else because there's too many
people not interested okay
ela's out zack's out if zack is out i
mean i'm interested in i'm just being a
good boy right now and av is training
you can't eat that i'm not yeah
i mean if i'm off diet i'm all in but
right now no i can't do it by the way
that treadmill i set up at my desk is
awesome so i deserve uh
fried chicken fried chicken
chicken fries what do you want to eat
because you're you're the preggy
i don't like deciding on the show
there's a i don't care deciding on the
show there's a combo in the whatsapp if
you want to look up a pretty good place
okay
that hurt
my knees
and then i sit down first class i'm like
trying to put the seat belt on
i love how hilly was like hildy you're
not far off husband
[Laughter]
that's how we do it that's how we do it
buddy we're all honest this is real [ __ ]
this can be a good interview and i'm not
here to like
do anything other than just learn about
you
heidi's hard to read like i don't know
if she's like
she's always smiling
and she's always smiling so how do you
read people like
oh my god wait this is a revolution like
usually when we have men talking about
you
she's boring she's a [ __ ] she's sour he
looks at you and says she's always
smiling
this is a this is a wonderful comment i
think this is like
so different than what we usually get
it's actually nice to see him being nice
to you for once
monotone monica over here yeah yeah
so i like that about him he's being nice
to my to hilo for once people always go
immediately for you
[Applause]
um
does she
i don't think i'm gonna be in this
interview probably right because it's
like right before the delivery sounds
like i don't want you to witness what
i'm going to have to do are you sure
[Laughter]
i don't want you to please
no if you can it'd be i think it's
always nice to have you on the
interviews
but don't stop me don't hold me back
cutting it really close to our due date
so i don't know well the end of j we
were thinking end of january is to do
this i think for the most part it's
pretty safe like i think the due date is
the beginning of february right they
moved it up a little bit well i got from
two different doctors like once said
it's february 2nd one said it's january
31st so
yeah so i think it's
like a week before that i think it's
it's pretty unusual to have it be like a
weaker yeah yeah i think i think it'll
be fine
i think it'll be fine
i'm gonna pay this guy a bunch of money
to fly out here
and not be able to do the show
but the thing is we're gonna
i think it'll be it should be fine it
really should all right well hold on
maybe we can do them
right because we have
i'll uh we have to make it work well
we'll figure it out we have to make it
goes into labor we'll just make it a
vlog or
oh my god
yeah that didn't feel right
hildy gang rise up
like the fact that he's
my size does she not like the fact that
he's my size he would never know with
her
but not far off you know her it was so
just like
she's like a neutral smile smiley woman
that's the difference yeah
a neutral smiley woman i mean i guess
it's a good thing
yeah thank you thank you i gotta say i
like it
this man does not hate women
well except olivia for no reason
no no he says that he was joking i think
he was doing stick i thought so too i
assumed so i wasn't really offended this
is the first man we've ever beefed with
on youtube who didn't come out with
straight misogyny immediately
love that
he's enlightened i'm becoming a fan i'm
telling you
i think i'm all in on this guy
i find him very interesting
i do
go through life smiling i go through
life
[Laughter]
all over the floor
i'm not coming to your stinky stupid
little podcast
and who's that girl too
oh what was that girl's name who got so
upset i was joking lady
olivia
olivia she took offense oh please ashley
ashley
you're actually now right at the
beginning of this video he promotes his
merch and there's one shirt that says um
don't look at me lady and he said i need
to wear this one for olivia and guess
what i bought it
right there
maybe he'll sign it for you
i would love [ __ ] on it he could shart
on it whatever whatever nick wants to do
to that shirt whatever
great now that there's chicken and
french fries
okay well anyway i can't wait to get him
out here i really can so it's exciting
we're making it work all right
you know
did we figure out something to eat or
you don't want to deal with it right now
i think i already ordered surprise lena
what did you get me
she said a salad
hey ethan do you want to be able to go
on flights
and airplanes
i won't talk about it right now do you
want to travel the world what kind of
salad did you get me
[Music]
garden salad oh you got rice ranch
is there meat on it
edit your name okay
[Music]
yeah making them cry seeing this long
list of burgers i'm like i don't know
do you see the bread for the burgers
it looks so crazy i was so stressed out
this morning i just hid in the closet
for a minute
you little stalking me and i just went
in the closet and closed the door
that's how i feel right now
vegan ranch like a vegan ranch pretty
good
well you know what this means it means
we can [ __ ] around tonight
exactly yeah
that's okay
thank you lina
thank you for being my strength
you do impossible things lena's doing a
possible thing
she's ordering fat guys salads from
vegan restaurants
it's not even real chicken
what am i gonna do told men
what are we gonna do without men
[Music]
men who call ela who make fun of ela for
being
not
fun
ela is a bad [ __ ]
when will the men understand that eel is
a bad [ __ ]
she's a ceo and self-made millionaire
she's hot as [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] would we do without elo
you no wonder you're all insults you
look at a girl like woman and you
criticize her
you would [ __ ] be lucky to even
even sniff her fart buddy
you [ __ ] virgin
[ __ ] you
rice gum the only reason women touch you
is because you're [ __ ]
apparently you're rich but i don't have
any evidence of that
well that's the only reason buddy
you're built like gumby
you want to talk about personalities
you got the personality of a
inmate
damn
toxic masculinity
[Music]
[ __ ] you
i heard steve will do it's having a kid
[ __ ] that
where would we be without men
to pay for women's abortions
where would we be
i heard they want to outlaw abortions
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
these conservatives they want to outlaw
abortions
i know you [ __ ] all gotta buy i know
you [ __ ] are the one getting them
what the [ __ ] you sounding like shaggy
it wasn't me
no no no scooby-doo
that's swaggy
[Music]
where would we be without men making
women sign ndas
and getting abortions
because it would hurt their public
record
wasn't there an actor or something who
did that he made her sign like a nda and
offered a 75 000 bucks
to get an abortion
oh my god
that happened recently
buddy
[Music]
but the someone offered
their partner money to get an abortion
or
girl i don't know
some girl he hooked up got pregnant and
she said no he said she would take the
75 000 sign this nda
where would we be without being like
that they're doing impossible things
they made abortion illegal in texas but
i'll tell you what ted cruz has had 20.
ted cruz has abortions like it's damn
buffet menu they work themselves to
death
[Music]
plan b ain't just uh
playing like skittles
tristan thompson who the [ __ ] tristan
cruz
khloe kardashians
or possibly they're back together i
don't let me look
huh yeah he's like he's cheated on her
like three times where would we be
without men
three times they're doing impossible
things
tristan cruz carries a [ __ ] tic tac
uh package with plan b
the first time he says here take a plan
b
you can hear it jiggling in his pocket
the first time he cheated on her was
when chloe was in labor
where would we be without men
they're doing impossible things
family family family family family
family family having a family
the ace family
they gave a house tour that you teased
uh about 20 minutes you trying to get me
to move on
i'm just reminding you because we still
haven't watched that let's see we have
the fouseytube got in a fight which is
awesome
you know
i don't think we can actually show that
it's pretty really deep island oh i mean
you want to watch it so bad he knocks
them out
so
actually yeah
yeah just one clean punch
he cold blocks him he's done he's just
out collapses to the ground he's doing
impossible impossible things right now
what is going on with him
how did foosie react to getting knocked
out he got it
[Music]
he was a little bit confused i think
half
because he was just knocked out in half
because he was super drunk
oh my god
bryce finally got that knockout
so true
still hasn't been paid for it though
in fact
apparently the ace family owes bryce
hall five million dollars for the fight
oh my god oh yeah that's well known they
never paid him they didn't pay any of
the fighters but what i was to say we'll
never see that money oh no but what i
was going to say is um
we know where that five million dollars
went
ace family's new house
that looks like a nice [ __ ] house
what
what
how did they scam their way into a new
house
dude what
scammed
dude i'm sorry what is happening number
five on trending you gotta love youtube
yeah you got
really they trended this it's number
five trending right now yeah and it was
posted yesterday
content is okay
jeffrey epstein be like yo take a tour
of my island number one trending
exactly
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
what an incredible home you guys
definitely deserve a beautiful home oh
who wrote that ryan cavanaugh's bots
best of the best
this home is what the [ __ ] bro
i can't okay let's watch this
is there any intel on how much they
spent on this house
[Music]
yeah so basically they owing these
fighters millions of dollars and they
took that money and bought themselves a
house
[Music]
i look like they just can't help but
flex immediately let's film
the house tour at night because the
house looks sexier at night and i said
no
and then where are we going right now
and now we're here
you guys should be homeless i'm sorry
not it's not they should
maybe not homeless
nobody should be homeless but
they definitely shouldn't live in a
[ __ ] mansion i mean not they
shouldn't be owning a house maybe they
should be renting you know like a little
duplex on a busy street
you know what i'm saying it's called
townhouse
you shouldn't be owning property
how long before they get uh evicted from
this one
[Music]
so as you read by today's title we are
giving you guys exclusives in the shower
so before we get into our new house tour
i do want to say
that we are going to try our best to
show as much as we can as we told you
guys in
our previous videos that we're trying to
do
about it
we can't be but obviously
you know
our house is our office
filming is our lives dude they're going
to find out where you live bro
what are you wearing
i don't even know what i'm wearing just
really get ready for me
[Music]
cam just sent me some wild [ __ ] dude
what is this bro that's ela in the
delivery room
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank god sanitary
i think that wouldn't be a problem spicy
sauce jalapeno
spicy placenta
did were you able to find how much they
they bought this house no i'm only
seeing a few articles on it it's just
mentioning the old house
i'm looking to
it says ace family's new 10 million
dollar house
that's an old article
november 25th 2021
oh is that about their old i'm telling
you it's it's referencing the old house
yeah there was probably just an update
to the article or something
listen
okay you gotta skip some crazy
i actually was and that's why i'm
wearing this guy there's some stuff
usually in the
shirt
can you guys go out there get out of the
bathroom
[Music]
what is going on with these people
what is happening with these people i
genuinely typical tour because we're
trying to yeah give me a [ __ ] try to
do things strategically so how can they
not read the room
and post this
when um
when they owe people money like
right i mean yeah this is where
brexital's money went 5 million bucks
bizarre
well like i said they're more concerned
with not appearing like they're rich
than anything yeah that was their main
driving force behind their last video so
before we got this house
i
literally saved
a picture of a door just like this
really wow that's so interesting
for the kids by our room upstairs in our
old house but they never she wanted to
come out because they were too far away
from us and like where are we usually
like
well this is still interesting you guys
don't judge us too hard
and
there's the play room
got the barbies got the toys to my
favorite things then
all the annoyance
you guys i mean like yeah capitalism is
failed experiments
and we are living in a failed state i
mean
i just i don't know that there's much
hope between this and v friends i really
think like there's just no hope
i mean it's disgusting our our world is
is cursed it is
cursed it's cursed
my wife
everyone okay hello
come on in the ace family movement
well they've got a popcorn machine in
the movie room you guys
i wonder if they make real popcorn in
the movie room any popcorn
that's so interesting that's so quirky
and cool that you could eat popcorn
this is an airbnb
no i think so
uh they this is no no no no you think so
or rental
i'm starting to suspect
yeah because they said they did say they
buy bought it but here's the thing
if in the next week or two
there isn't like a article about exactly
all the details they're housed and they
definitely are renting it
because every time anyone buys a house
there's these psychos in city hall that
leak the info
to variety and dirt or whatever the [ __ ]
so popcorn machine was the tell to me
like yep yep me too i don't know that's
such an airbnb thing no i've seen this
in a lot of uh
[Music]
movie theater rooms
when we were shopping for houses this is
like the [ __ ]
stupidest dumb [ __ ] like the thing right
now is the movie theater room with the
popcorn machine yeah fair enough i mean
i i don't know that but that's just
that's my bet
well if it was a long-term
rental there wouldn't be furniture in it
i mean how could unless they had cash on
hand how could they get credit to i have
a giant foreclosure i'm assuming they
had to buy it with cash it could be a
long-term rental furniture
yeah furnished rental
they would have to buy this cash
nobody's loaning the money period right
so yeah they used bryce's money they
used bryce's money to buy a new house
straight up dude
[Music]
what are you guys watching huh
but now
we are blessed and fortunate enough to
have one in our new house
and we love it it's amazing
whenever
the vibe it could be i mean they furnish
that whole house like pretty fast right
how you can't furnish your house that
fast especially with all the
port closures like it takes
dude we're shopping for a new couch
we heard it takes like six months to get
a new couch now because it gets stuck at
port for so long
so this thing i don't know man yeah
interesting theories interesting
they're being like so
i mean i guess to be fair that
it makes sense that they don't want to
reveal where it is but like you said i
mean you know from personal experience
when big
houses like this get sold it gets
reported in the media and i've been
googling since we started this video and
there's no intel at all on where this
house is yeah you can't hide it it'll
come out yeah from these dirt.com
exactly would have this [ __ ]
well it
it
yeah
this is austin by the way someone took
this photo i don't know what it means
it's because he's wearing a mcdonald's
set
was that mcdonald's like high luxury
brand
i'm pretty sure they'd say that
mcdonald's sent that to him
in this video
dude can
okay all right
[Music]
it looks like it's staged
this is a staged house
this is a staged house it does look like
it's staged this is not this is staged
there's something fishy here i agree
you're right and that popcorn machine
never been used
i think it's an air [ __ ] for sure
it seems like it's airbnb
wait what are they doing we're going to
be staged
i don't know it just does something to
me to my body to my life
to my mind to my soul
i just love the vibes it makes me so
happy you got the mirror i don't have
people with that look at the idiot in
this [ __ ]
because their image is everything i mean
they went for a year
being like everybody who's saying our
house is going for sale is a [ __ ]
liar hater [ __ ] right and then all of a
sudden they're lot they lying bro they
lying what a weasley little liar dude
what a freaking liar literally lying
these are this is the most staged room
i've ever seen yeah these are like the
most staged mirrors two huge mirrors
right next to each other is that stage
dead stage
you guys are right you guys are all
right can they hear the water that
outside looks like every influencers
house like the one that they all ran
when they first got to l.a ricegum phase
they all had that waterfall and here's
silly boy
stop showing your kids i don't even like
to see their kids
[Music]
ever since we watched that last video
and some commenter was like this dude
has two hairlines
i'm sitting here with no hairline this
guy's got two you gotta [ __ ] share
the wealth dude
by the way we looked into one of these
self-playing pianos because i thought it
was pretty cool and i bailed when i
found out how much it was what was it
like 100 000 bucks yeah
so that piano i think they had that in
the old house yeah mistaken yeah they
had
it's their friend that's all they can
they they do they did have it because we
were making jokes about buying it
whenever they're selling all their okay
so i think um i think that
i saw posts about them trying to sell
their old furniture online
so i think he kept the piano
but the rest of the [ __ ] is definitely
staged
unless you can find some crossover to
prove like this room if you can't prove
to me this room is not 100 staged dude
like
but maybe i mean this is so staged look
at this furniture and the table and
everything
totally no it's like
every that's what every house looks like
that's the same couch that they had it
is
yeah are you serious how do you know
that
i'm looking at the picture right now
oh [ __ ] me in the ass it has to be the
same right maybe they rearranged it that
a little bit it's not like maybe they
just took their furniture with them um i
don't
that's no that's a different couch bruh
is it yeah different it's different look
at the pillow sure it's not rearranged
no this one has oh you're right a
cushion that's a different color that
one doesn't have cushions it's kind of
close though
yeah it's similar but it's a different
couch
yeah i feel like they would have kept
the one on the right is nicer this one
is straight up stage stage furniture is
dog [ __ ]
it's just fake furniture like you ever
been to a house not always fake
furniture but it's like fake beds the
beds are like air mattresses yeah it's
just to make the house look okay yeah
you know
yes
oh why did that happen
happened looks so cozy comfortable
look at this staged room yeah dude
now
to our amazing kitchen
to me
this is way better than an old kitchen
this is triple the size
where you have gas
we don't have to watch our babies in ice
water
chef will made us some
what you call that pasta and chicken
what would you call that are you [ __ ]
dumb
she's like pasta and chicken what do you
mean maybe he's asking the type fusilli
what would you call that
way hold on i gotta see if you're
correct
made this for us and he was hoping
there's a name to the dish
let's see what she's let's see if he's
content with her saying pasta and
chicken
what would you call that pasta and
chicken
delicioso
he accepted boston chicken
he didn't push back on that
this [ __ ] guy it shows on the uh
fridge oh yeah i love the fridge nice
and show us the fridge
everything just like blends in
and it's like
smooth how did they if they bought this
house
how the
unless they move to buffalo real quick
stan push
and it opens
i mean this looks like a very exciting
this is the freezer you know
don't got [ __ ] as far as i'm concerned
everything in this house
yeah this is brilliant that's all bryce
halls yo bryce hall you need to roll up
and collect your deck
[Music]
i don't know why but i can watch this
this [ __ ] idiot walk through his
house for hours
i literally just can't get enough for
breaks at all
here all right here we go in the big
reveal a b
all you do is the fridge stage
to heart
extend push dude i know how it works
you push it and it opens
what the hell dude
so this is the freezer
okay what do we got there
what do we got there ice cream um
tortilla it's pizza roll it's a [ __ ]
pizza roll
i think it's just not show you guys if
you did fine like put that up
does this
look like the same place no his house is
way more epic than that show me the
kitchen and i'll tell you
yeah we were just looking at the kitchen
no no that's not the way
no that's probably not the main nah his
house is way more epic bro than this i
think cam might have found it
send it but don't put it on screen for
crazy well i just want you guys to see
it okay yeah yeah yeah
dude he's got pizza rolls yeah those are
totini i mean for the kids obviously but
you know
we stan pizza rolls don't we
i got pizza rolls in my [ __ ] freezer
for theater who am i why are you eating
this you know who eats on
i don't me why it's taking so long to
load but why is this the biggest [ __ ]
oh crazy their new studio looks crazy
it's like a huge set like
yeah
right i might be on to something that's
a good point
i needed that i needed a short one
okay so all we got for you guys you
never made that food for them chef
boyardee
[Applause]
they always gotta act like they're so
[ __ ] rich and so important chefo chef
made it for us yeah
chef b over here exactly
those are bryce yeah i know chef boy or
d
those pizza rolls belong to bryce oh god
oh yeah everything in that house is
bryce's man
ice cream pops
and some
tostinos i called it that's all we got i
know toasted when i see them
that's the biggest box of tostitos i
ever seen in my life now the fridge
oh [ __ ]
okay i'm sorry
so now the fridge
just don't mind we just didn't come to
prepare for this
house tour we usually have everything
you know
all decorated what are you saying what
are you what is he
saying that the fridge is too messy to
show
that's him uh
about to take a bite of chef's food
there
yeah that's their beautiful kitchen
um but it's dirty
might as well we're showing everything
out here
okay so
these two should not be prospering i
mean really
this is just a spit in the face of every
working american
sorry shuffle
hey
come on it looks like smells like my
[ __ ] candle
isn't it
the house looks super nice though i'm
not gonna hate it like it's beautiful i
mean
super polished super high end looking
[Music]
right yeah yeah the chat is saying you
missed a self report i did i'll go back
and something came with the house
i'd like to talk with joey
guys does he have his jet ski in the
pool
i just can't keep eating
you know home-cooked meals i like to
also enjoy junk food
sorry shuffle
sorry chef boyardee
did i miss it or i don't know this seems
i'm not sure i'll let you know whatever
yeah or if you find it just time stamp
it for me i get it bro
yo this looks like a very expensive
house
okay this looks like as expensive as
their one they got in woodland hills
depending on where it is in l.a
it really depends where it is i guess if
you're in like the valley maybe it's a
five million dollar house but
if it's in the valley i think it's like
seven
you think so
if you got that in hollywood it'd be
like 16 million yeah
he said the pizza rolls came with the
house
he did say that yeah he said the
tortinos
he messed up the pronunciation okay
that is a weird self report
how is it possible that pizza rolls
and what situation leftover from the
last uh tenant or the last that's it no
your the agent doesn't leave tortillo
tortinos in the house hold on
hold on now i gotta go back and find
that
sorry okay so all we got for you guys
family is some damn
ice cream pops and some
toastinos
that's all we got
who got those
i think they came with the house
no that was a joke that's a joke you
guys are we sure
i think i think the it's a joke
i mean it came with that if we wanted to
do a real deep dive
the kids didn't know how to work the tv
they said the volume's not working
theater
that stuff is hard to get to work
yeah
of the home which have
a functional pool it's actually is it
warm right now warm right now you can
really see behind the pool they're
running the heat on open pool and in uh
in the winter it's been like 40 [ __ ]
eight degrees at night here let's go
baby
working pool water department hasn't
shut it off we also have a little vibe
here i hate this why are they do why do
they have this house i'm not gonna show
them up top jim this is nicer than that
thumbs up right now i'll do it because
the water the water isn't that cool the
best thing about this pool is
it's not the waterfalls
or the lights
it's the alarm we have an alarm inside
the pool
safety is number one
so what is that kids or animals or
something how does it know if a kid fell
in
versus a normal person but
i imagine that's you're supposed to have
a gator on your pool otherwise like
you can't get insurance
it just it just you'll stop when there's
stop
all inside
we're getting alerts it's amazing
safety's number one so instead of having
an ugly gate around the pool yeah i'm
not trusting that device to make sure my
kids don't drown
i'm putting the button okay
he's like hold on baby let me mute this
damn pool thing
we're filming a video let me mute this
damn pool alarm keeps going off he's got
an alarm it's amazing it's the best
thing ever
it's bryce's pool that's bryce's water
bryce owns that water
he does
how the [ __ ] they get this all stacked
with arcades already it's pricey arcade
no but for real how did they get all
these arcade games in there already
so either they already had it just moved
it you know
i don't think they had i never saw any
arcade games in their old place so over
here
we got the arcade games this
entertainment room fits
two of our rooms back at the old house
why did you do that
mega please drink
yeah that is from the old house
okay i guess i'm not the expert on hbm
now if you come over here we're gonna
show you guys the park
slash
i kept my boxing ring
okay katherine whisperer is [ __ ] so
big i've seen it catherine hates the
boxing ring
there's so much room for activity
dude how are people not figure out where
they live like they're showing
everything that backyard's super
distinct
to remove
the box hey i got things but
this is so mysterious isn't it
there's no
explanation for them having this house
what the [ __ ] is that is also another
waterfall so it matches that they have
two waterfalls you guys
austin got this for me last year for
christmas why does she have like [ __ ]
maple i mean i'm not going to i don't
want to be her i don't see vulgar but
another waterfall so it matches that
song
i think that's like a photo or or maybe
it's a painting painting but why is
there
okay
i'm not gonna be [ __ ] vulgar about it
but
honey i missed almost exactly a year ago
[Music]
why is this happening
my favorite parts
i mean definitely nicer than the last
house i would say without a doubt
a couple years
i mean the only other explanation is
that they've been
buying this house for a while knowing
they were going to leave that one
i don't know
i can't wait though for to get leaked to
say how much they've spent on it i'm
dying to know
all right
what do we think
i think it's their house
however
i think that's bryce's family
it's rice's house those are bryce's kids
that's bryce's house he gets the kids in
the settlement mm-hmm
bryce would be like all right you don't
owe me the 5 million but i want your
kids they'd be like deal
and all of their possessions ace family
would sell their kids to sell that
[ __ ] me dude
all right i mean that's basically it
you know
i've been going for a while
i know i don't want to go too long
because he lives in pain her back hurts
we'll get her home
almost three hours oh my god how do we
do that
freaking hours what and god's green [ __ ]
and damn [ __ ] planet earth [ __ ] my
tits coming my ass and pissing my
[ __ ] mouth
holy [ __ ] wow [ __ ] balls
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] wow
[ __ ] fully [ __ ]
okay
oh my god [ __ ]
wow
balls
[ __ ]
you gotta love how we click baited
pewdiepie
pewdiepie slams ryan kavanagh
oh well hold on hold on i just thought
of a better title
pewdiepie slams ryan kavanagh
i mean we got to do the ace family new
house tour people love that
so how should we format this
pewdiepie slams kavanagh love that
nicocado maybe just say nicotto it's too
wordy
nicocado comma
ace ace family new house tour
do we love that do we hate it hey fred
do we love it slams ryan kavanaugh
nickacado
maybe pewdiepie pewdiepie slams ryan
cavanaugh is that good in the in the
to lead with
maybe not maybe the other ones ace
family new house tour is pretty good
yeah nicka cotto is pretty good you know
me i vote nico cotto goes first yeah
nico cotto's pretty good
nick acado is
coming on the show yeah
nicotto said yes
it's pretty good
it's an announcement
nickacado
you could say nicoto announcement
new
new bryce family house tour bryce family
bryson's house tour
new ace family house store is pretty fun
yeah
new ace family house tour
family shows bryce hall's house
i think the joke is too it's too
complicated to convey in the title so we
so hold on we've got we've got
the bryce family
ace in the brace family
we've got
[ __ ]
a
[Music]
ace ace family new mansion
ace family's new house store we got that
comma
nickacado
comma
this comes this comes from love that's
pretty good pewdiepie defends me against
the villain ryan cavanaugh [ __ ]
fighter
pewdiepie slams harvey i mean ryan yeah
because ryan cavanaugh doesn't need to
be the title hold on hang on hang on
hang on you want to do that again zach
it's [ __ ] friday holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] fall day
yeah [ __ ] finally
weekend baby [ __ ]
it's pretty good we should just make
that the title
just the britney and white club game
britney spears plus white cloud gabe
collaboration announcement we're all to
our announcement
ace family new mansion tour
ace family's new mansion
families new mansion
or do you like tour better what do you
guys think
i like the men
dan
dan
in the title
my dad
i think he went through the floor bro
you're gonna knock over too hard machine
you're going too fast
well if you want to wrap it up we got to
get the title locked in this is
important show notes
pewdiepie loves me i see i'm looking at
the chat huh here we go good sugar
speech by loves me
bryce hall graciously funds new ace
family house
ace family's pity mansion
nicoto slams pewdiepie's cavernousy
[Music]
i like you guys have good ideas in the
um
nicotto moves in with the ace family
ace family's airbnb
[Music]
ace family new house
nicka cotto pewdiepie defends me
it's pretty good
or maybe we could clickbait a little bit
with like nickacado new nicocado drama
it's a straight up i mean it's not true
but it's good you could say enough
got a new house with pewdiepie
i mean it's it's a little
true ate pewdiepie
mukbang's pewdiepie yeah nicotto did say
in his video that he doesn't like the
clickbait that we do oh
he was like they're always these these
titles it's like we're getting a divorce
we're quitting youtube
well he sees them
right so let's do nick new nicotto drama
that'll get good that'll get him nice
and
riled up
nicotto attacks ashley and hildy hilda
you guys are funny i like these
suggestions
we try to get pewdiepie sued
it was an episode about when people go
too far and in the little
clip i saw it was the gay station
episode they were showing a promotion
what the freak
ace family new house
nickacado
drama pewds defends me
it flipped all right let's just we'll
deal with that afterwards yeah i enjoy
reading the comments so pretty funny any
uh donations you want to read dan
sure pewdiepie
that's good
just a lot today you did so mine was a
little flicked yeah sorry let's see
somebody
is it cold in here or where we go oh
freezing it's clean today
i could turn the heat on yeah get the
discord
yeah i see it um
beauty [ __ ]
uh
mad science
slaying test donated 20 said screw that
bathroom idea if dan and queen
klein get cool chairs i declare everyone
gets to design their own throne who's
with me
say what
because she had the bed and i have the
scorpion chair oh yeah everybody else is
sitting in all these lame ass normal
office chairs
that'd be
donated fifty dollars i just wanted to
wish you all happy holidays and thank
you for making
a
peek at amazon
i think that must
have meant that must have been
autocorrect work at amazon a little more
bearable for me ps really love the
leftovers podcast and you all accurate
criticism of bezos and the company
environment thank you don't let them
figure out your identity they'll
incinerate you
uh pseudo donated and stay don't don't
get off task now focus i don't want you
get fired 200
oh my god artists who made all of those
h3 crew figurines oh
those were really cool
what's their name
uh well their screen names pseudo
um
remember i think that's the they're
talking about the ones that were they
were all like in cge like they weren't
actually bears yeah and everybody had
like a different theme one oh yeah those
are so yeah those are really cool i'd
love to can you pull it up the crew
checked them out together
yeah we saw them all uh i guess we never
did talk about on the show
but yeah we were all sharing them uh
amongst each other you can find that
real quick
yeah they were very cool
money more renders i can show as well
family family family family thank you
thank you pseudo thank you thank you
family family family family hauser
donated 20 bucks i wanted to donate in
honor of the behind the scenes video
because i recently rejoined as a member
and they are quality hey shout out to a
b they're so creative and so well edited
shout out to ab
and the family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family and family from
family how do we feel about this like
dark evening
oh me and zach worked on that oh you
concocted that together
zach made it but yeah it was a project
yeah a bam
donated 100 euros and said you should
look at telltale channel he covers all
the mega extremism in the church
he himself was in a cult and moved to
new york because of persecution he's
very even ahead in the comments not
hateful at all people he comments on are
also absurdly funny uh telltale okay
i'll check it out yo somebody suggested
pewdiepie is getting sued by triller
which is [ __ ] hilarious pewdiepie
being
pewdiepie sued by triller pewdiepie be
like what what the [ __ ] yeah everyone
will be watching that ace family slams
ryan cavanaugh
nicotine avocado house tour
how about how about
ryan about pewdiepie
nicotto and ace family all being sued by
trailer
it's pretty funny
uh gabriel donate 100 said uh jollibee's
ads are off the rails i use them in my
english and communications class because
they're so funny and dramatic check them
out really let me check i wish i had
seen that uh when we were talking about
jelly beans jolly beat let me look make
a note jollibee are you gonna look it up
right now yeah i don't know might as
well i mean the food's not here right
joel donated 50
uh
pounds said i'm a fat fetishist i'm
pretty sure nick's content is in part
geared to fat fetishes specifically
those who are into gaining slash feeding
okay that's yeah that makes sense that
would explain it
for sure i would certainly explain some
things here this is a jolly bee
uh valentine's commercial
you know what dude in honor of pewdiepie
we're gonna put this [ __ ] thing at
1.5
it's way too slow man
i never forget your smile when i first
laid my eyes on you this is sick
fried chicken
[Music]
no way
oh my god
this is pretty ridiculous this person
was right
i'm expecting like a joke or something i
promise to make you laugh
[Music]
i love that the whole relationship is
built around a fast food restaurant
i'll be patient with you i'll be patient
with you at all times
this [ __ ] lives for this fast
food restaurant get a life dude
i promise i will never change
i let me guess what they catered at
their wedding reception
by the way we're watching this on 1.5
speed
yeah
so slow let's go
let's go warp speed yeah let's kick it
up a notch
it's like normal speed
[Music]
wait
wait it wasn't wait
he got cocked by her
wait what the [ __ ] happened he got
cucked by her
i wanted you to be the happiest girl
he's in love with her but she's marrying
someone else
even if we didn't end up together jesus
[ __ ] supposed to make you wanna
buy the food i'm not going there and
getting cuts what the hell
yo i'll tell you what man i'm gonna tell
you what if i'm getting married and my
[ __ ] bride
is turning around and giving him one
last look to her boy she met at jubilee
i'm [ __ ] worried man
i don't want you being
to my
[ __ ] that bro
but those who continue to love without
conditions
what the guy who eats jolly be lost yeah
yeah
right
what mark what is that marketing dude he
got friend zoned into being the best man
you know
deep level friends
yeah
whoa that was good
[ __ ]
it's like eat our food and you'll be
friend zoned
oh what do you think about that ela
yeah i saw these they're super funny
that's oh okay
angel
oh wait who's the
angel um who is the banjo saint okay
wait i never saw this
i never saw this oh these are great oh
yeah so scorpion dan saint olivia oh
starkiller lawyer saint olivia where'd
that come from oliver twist cam
because
yeah
i love it though thank you just love it
handsome
honorable judge ethan love that
librarian sam
[Laughter]
olivia as brittany
damn you got two olivia i love that
there's gary the beach ball baseball
killer
love
the don ark force love
corona
dan the wizard
mm-hmm cam uh as his snowman from the
holiday merch
uh bailiff ela
sick a-i-e-n
nick
ela with the cat paws yeah
someone put in some work to it
oh yeah the five percent
that's the one
uh white paw game
game yes
ethan the type of guy who float when he
smells pie what the hell
it reminds me of that um
what's that okay i'm not gonna get
vulgar on you
there's that really fun famous statue
that uh
takashi made yeah where this anime
character is doing a lasso with his own
jizz yeah
god reminds me of that yeah
cringe hazmat
uh monty
foot soldiers
uh zach the sound
rock star mode that is like the coolest
[ __ ] thing the god papa of course
crippling anxiety oh man
the turkish firefighter
oh the shredder cake
yeah who is this
it's so accurate exactly
so awesome oh good going dandy yeah
and the curse sonic he's so fast
that's it so shout out to sudos that's
an insane amount of work they put in
there king's dark titings
thank you man what a talent and wow
super talented
super cool
love that
yeah so jubilee's out by the way
he was gonna leave me for some non-fast
food eating slowly saint olivia came
from her helping the homeless uh oh
saint olivia that makes sense sure
the the needle exchange the other way
yes the needle exchange stuff what a
scene
anything else there
uh
just seeing if there's any last minute
little messages
oh this one's for you ian somebody uh
somebody wanted to know
who's hyped for the uh
spider-man movie
coming out ian's going to the midnight
showing i mean everybody's hyped
i'm not i don't i'm really not that
hyped i'm going to tell you but i can
tell the general excitement for it is
pretty high yeah yeah i feel like they
come out too frequently mm-hmm yeah i'm
just i'm totally that's a good point
with the
marvel movies so i'm thinking about how
excited i'm for the new matrix and how i
was excited for every matrix that came
out after the first it was like three
years in between you waited you forgot
about it right
and then you remember the second and
third came out rapid fire actually but
there was a big gap between the first
and the two sequels
i think they came out only like six
months apart or something because they
shot him at the same time so it was like
no way six months
yeah they came out whatever those movies
sucked
oh [ __ ] we're getting live updates from
there
i hope he's not mad at me
for what i've interviewed
celebrities on this show
[Music]
and we love him we're interested in him
we want him here but we have reached
terms
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got a deal you better get your ass
out here
i don't care how fat you are and how
uncomfortable it is
squeeze your ass into that seat ashley
will literally carry you if she has to
exactly
we'll have a whole army of ashley's too
it's 84 yes by the way
oh i love that
shout out to the nicocado fans
agreed who we love
all righty that's it right dan we got
anything else to read off
uh no let's wrap it up well my friends
happy birthday to hilda
who is pregnant who is beautiful
who is everything you are the everything
i love you so much and uh i'm so excited
to spend the weekend with you me too
and um
yeah we're gonna have a fun time it's
exciting i'm really looking forward to
the weekend
we're really looking forward to the
weekend
and we're here we made it yay
i'm rubbing it because he's moving right
now he moves so much it's crazy you can
feel like his whole foot like the other
night you put your hand here you could
feel a whole foot being like
it's crazy
he's gonna be here so soon
yeah we enjoy our these last moments of
newborn world free newborn world
anyway we stan a queen queen hilda thank
you everybody i hope you all have a
great weekend new leftovers on
sunday
new bts
right now
yeah in fact i'll i'll post it right
this second
why not all right guys
have a good weekend
now
you're watching h to the three three
four
you're waiting for
is
[Music]
two
yo what's